In this course you will improve your user
interface and user experience design skills
by building a mobile app. Instructor, Joseph
Brendan is a great designer and great teacher.
Hey, guys, my name is Joseph, Brandon. And in
this course, I am going to show you how to design
a mobile app from scratch. Now, this mobile
app will be a stock investing mobile app
that users can use to invest in the stocks of
companies that they would like to invest in.
So here is a demonstration of the app that we
are going to design. Now over here, we have
the splash screen of the app, which is what's
going to show up when you launch the app. Now,
let's go to the next page here. Now, this is
the page where the user will have to select
their next action, which is either to log in as
an existing user or to get started as a new user.
So I'll go ahead and click on get started, just
like a new user would do. And here on this page,
the new user will be required to sign up to this
application with an email address, a phone number
and a password. Now, when the new user doors that
the new user will be taken to this page, where
the new user will have to enter a verification
code that's been sent to the phone number of that
new user. Now, when the phone number of the new
user is verified, it means that the new user is
now a registered user on this application, and the
next thing the user is going to do is to click on
the Proceed button here. And when the user does
that, the user will be taken to the homepage of
the application, which is this page here. And here
on the homepage of this application. Over here,
the account balance of the user will be displayed
here. Also, the user will have a button here
that can be used to fund the account on
this application. And right over here,
the user will have a list of recent transactions
that they have carried out on this application.
Now coming down here, the user will see a banner
here that they can click on to get a referral link
that can be used to invite friends to have an
account on this app. Now, at the bottom here,
we have the navigation section of this app.
Currently, we are on the homepage of the app.
Now let's navigate to the InVEST page, which is
the page where the user will have the features
that they can use to invest in stocks. So I'd come
here, and I'll click on invest. When I do that,
I'll be taken to the InVEST page, which
is this. And over here on the InVEST page,
you can see that we have a display
of cash and assets owned by the user.
And right after that, over here, we have a
list of top stocks that the user can invest in.
And also, we have the investment portfolio of
that user over here, which is a list of all the
investments that the user had made on this app.
Now let's say the user is trying to invest in one
of the stocks listed here, let's say this one,
yeah. Now, if the user clicks on it, the user
will be taken to the details page of that stock
that they clicked on. And on this details page,
we are going to have information about the
stock and the company that owns the stock.
Now if the user likes what they see here, the user
will go ahead to click on the InVEST button here.
And when the user clicks on that button, the user
will be required to enter the amount that they
wish to invest in that stocks with. Now when the
user enters the amount and the user clicks on the
Proceed button here, the user will see a summary
of the investment that they are about to make. And
when the user is okay with what they see here in
the summary. The user will be required to enter
their secrets pin here, and then click on the
InVEST button here. And when the user does that,
it means that the investment has been successful.
So this app that I just demonstrated here is
what we are going to design in this course from
scratch. Now before we start designing this app,
I would love to break down the stages of our
workflow for this project, so that you can
understand In the execution process of designing
products that are actual business solutions.
So here are the stages of our workflow. First
things first, the stakeholders of this project,
which is the owner of the project,
or the company we are working for,
will present us with a problem that they would
want us to design for. Now, when they present
these problems on us, they are also going to tell
us about the users, which are the people facing
the problem that they want us to design for.
Now, after that, the stakeholders will state
their expected goals for the project. Now after
the stakeholders presents a problem and states,
their expected goals to us, the next
stage of our workflow will be for us,
the UX designers to empathize with the users. Now
after we empathize with the users patient problem,
we are going to create what we call a problem
statement. And after creating this problem
statements, the next stage of our workflow will
be the stage where we will have to come up with
ideas that can be best business solutions to the
problems highlighted in the problem statement.
Now, when we are able to get an idea for
the problems in the problem statement,
the next action will be for us to design that
idea into a testable prototype. And after
designing that idea into a testable prototype, we
will go ahead to test the design to be sure that
it is able to solve the problems in the problem
statement. So let's get to work. Now outcome here
in figma. And I'll use a fig jam file to walk
on all the analytical parts of our workflow.
So let's create a fig jam file. And to do that,
come here and click on the new fig jam File button
there. When you do that, you have created a junk
file as easy as that. And I'd like to mention that
if you are new to using fie jam, you have nothing
to worry about. It's a really simple tool to use.
Just follow along, and you'd see that at the
end of this course, you would be good with using
feature. So I'll close this. And the next thing
I'll do after creating a fifth gem file is to give
the fifth gem file a name. So I'll call this
stocks, big jam, you can call it whatever you
want to call it. Now after giving this junk pile
in him. The next thing to do is to outline the
stages of our workflow here in peach jam. So let's
do that. So first things first out, zoom into 200%
outcome here to zoom in and out Select Zoom
to 200% here. And when I zoom in to 200% out,
use a square shape here to write down
a headline for our workflow. So I would
keep this there, I would select the text to now
so that I can write my text. And I would say,
workflow stages, then outcome here, and I'll align
the text to the left. And I'll change the color of
the rectangle to this. And that. Okay, so the
next thing I'll do is to have sticky notes,
were out outline the workflow stages in. So
to create a sticky notes in peach jam, I would
come here and now select the sticky note tool
here. When I select it out, come here and out,
click on the big jam Canvas to have this. Now
let's select this. And let's expand the width
to align with our sticky notes. So first things
first, I will change the color of my sticky notes
to this, then I'll click on this Add text
placeholder here. So that I can write down
all of those workflow stages that I talked about.
So I would like to make this a list. And I'd like
it to be a bulleted list. So I would come here
and I would select the bulleted list property
here. Then I would write down the first workflow
stage, which is this, it says stakeholders present
the problem and the users facing the problem. Now
I'll create another list item, which is going to
be the next stage of our workflow. And that's
going to be where the stakeholders will define
the goals for this project. So I would say define
goals. Let's come here. Let's create some space
here. Now let's outline the next stage of
our workflow. After the goals are defined,
we view X designers will empathize with the users.
So let's come here. Let's create the space also.
Now After we the UX designers empathize with the
users, the next stage of our workflow will be
where we are going to create a problem statement.
So I would say, creates problem statements.
So let's come here, let's create the space. Now
after we create a problem statements, the next
stage of our workflow will be the stage, where we
are going to come up with an idea that can solve
the problems listed in the problem statement. Now,
after we come up with a best idea that can solve
the problems in the problem statement, the next
stage of our workflow will be the stage where
we are going to design that idea into a testable
prototype. So I would say design prototype here.
And after we design that idea into a testable
prototype, we are going to move over to the
next stage of our workflow, which is going
to be the stage where we are going to test
that idea that we have designed into a
prototype. So I would just call that test and
have that spaced. Now we have outlined our
workflow stages here. So just to make this better,
I would select all of these and I would make
all of the text bold. To have that outcome here,
I would select this text, and I'll make it bold
also. Now zoom back to 100%. To see what we have,
and this is okay, so I'll use the hand tool,
which is this, you can come here to click on it to
select it or just press the H key on your keyboard
to have it selected. And now grab and shift a
canvas to this point. So now we have outlined our
workflow stages here right. Now the next thing to
do is for AWS to outline all of the actions that
will be taken on that each of this workflow stage.
So this means that we are now going to break down
each of these stage one after another, so that we
know what actions to take at each of these stage
and how to optimize for our results. So I would
select the Move tool here by clicking on it or by
pressing the V key on my keyboard to select it.
And I would come here, I would select the
square tool there so that I can create
this shape like this. And over here, I would write
a text inside this shape. And that text will be
this first stage out select all of this text here,
then I'll use CTRL. C, if you are using a Mac,
its command C, I would use that to copy that text.
And I'll paste it inside this question like this.
Now expand this to this point. Now this is the
first stage of our workflow right outcome here
now. And I'd have a sticky note here, right under
that. Now in this sticky note out write out what's
going to happen at this stage, which is the first
stage of our workflow. Now this stage is the stage
where the stakeholders will present the problem
to us. And also let us know about the users that
they want us to design for. So in this course, I
would like us to assume that we have a stakeholder
somewhere or we have a company somewhere that
wants us to design an app that you can use to
invest in stocks for them, right. So I'll
paste this in here in this sticky note,
which says users find it really hard to invest
in stocks using existing investment apps due to
information overload and complex presentation of
information on the apps. Now, who are the users,
the users are stock investors in Nigeria. So this
so having this here means that the stakeholders
have presented us with a problem and the
users facing the problem. So this is sorted.
So let's change the color of the sticky notes.
Something like this to differentiate it from
this one here. And let's come here. Let's change
this, to that to differentiate it also. So this
is the first stage of our workflow. And we have
seen what's going to happen here at this stage.
So let's look at the next stage here, which is the
stage where the stakeholders will define the goals
of the project. So I would come here, I would
select this and now duplicate it to duplicate
is Ctrl D. If you are using a Mac, its command
D. So I'll duplicate this and our habits to here.
I will take out this text inside this
shape. And out writes define goals there.
I can have in brackets saved by stakeholders. So
I'll keep this here. Now outcome here also out
duplicates these and out habits, they're right
on the dish shape, which is a square shape,
right. So inside the sticky notes, I'll take
all of these out and out. also assume that
we have stakeholders somewhere who sent us
the goals. That's the ones for this project.
So let's assume that the stakeholders sent us
this as their goal. And it says, research and help
us us simplify every task needed to make a stock
investment. So what we have here so far is this,
the stakeholders have presented us with a problem
and B users facing the problem. And they have
gone ahead to define their expected goal for this
project. And the expected goal is that they want
us to research and help users simplify every task
needed to make a stock investment. So let's move
over to the next stage of our workflow, which is
the stage where we the UX designers will have to
empathize with the users facing the problem.
So I would come here, I'll duplicate this,
I would have this here. And I would say empathize.
Now I have this here also. And I'll take out all
we have here. And at this empathize stage, this
is actually the stage where we the UX designers
will now get to work. So what do we
do at this stage? What are the actions
that we need to carry out at this stage, so that
we can say that we have properly empathized with
the users facing the problem. So what we
are going to do is to interview the users
face to face or send out surveys digitally to
the users. The purpose for that is so that we
can understand the problems from the perspective
of the people facing the problem. Now after that,
we are going to create what we call user personas,
all under this empathize stage. So out, make this
a list, just like this, to have that organized
properly. And when we are done with the empathize
stage, by carrying out these two actions here, the
next thing we are going to do is to move over to
the next stage of our workflow, which is the stage
where we will have to create a problem statements.
So I would come here, I would have this here. And
I'll change that to create problems statements,
and have this stay here. So at this stage,
where you the UX designer will be needed
to create a problem statements, what you do
to create a problem statements, it's easy,
just state the problem of the users with all
you have gathered from the previous stage,
which is the empathize stage. So after you have
interviewed the users to understand the problems
from their perspective, and you have created
user personas for each of the user, what you
do is you'd use all of that data to properly
state the problem that the users are facing.
Now when you create the problem statement,
which is you stating the problem properly,
the next thing you do is to move to the next stage
of our workflow, which is the idea stage. Now,
when you get to the idea stage, let's have
this here. When we get to the idea stage,
the actions that you take at the idea stage are
simple actions. All you'd have to do with this,
launch a brainstorming session, then
during the brainstorming session,
vote for the best idea, when you vote for the
best idea, select the idea with the highest votes.
And there you have gotten an idea that you can
then take to the next stage of our workflow,
which is the stage where we are going
to design that best idea into a testable
prototype. So before we go there, let's select
this and let's make it a list like this.
Now, let's come here and let's look at the next
stage here, which is the design prototype stage.
And when you get to this stage, what are the
actions that you need to take for you to properly
design a workable prototype, we are going to look
at the actions now. So out have this the here I'll
take all of these out. And the actions that we are
going to take to properly design a prototype are
all of this. First things first, we are going
to create an information architecture for the
best idea that we got from the idea stage. When
we create that in commission architecture, we
are going to use that information architecture to
create what we call a low fidelity prototype. Now,
after we create that low fidelity prototype, we
are going to test the low fidelity prototype.
And when the test is successful, we are going
to go ahead to create a high fidelity prototype
for that best idea that we got from the idea
stage. Now, after we create the high fidelity
prototype, we are going to move over to the next
stage of our workflow, which is the stage where
we are going to need to test that high fidelity
prototype. So I would come here, I'd have this
here, I would say test prototype. And I'll bring
this here, I can just say usability testing here.
And that's all. Let's come here, let's make all
of these illest. And that's okay. So what we have
here is a proper breakdown of our workflow. So I
like to connect all of this so that we understand
that these stages are to be followed one after
another. So I would select the connector tool
here, you can see where my mouse cursor is on,
click on it to select it, I would come here out,
select this point, click hold and drag. And
I would connect with this other point here,
I would select this also connected here. I'll
do that for all of these other items. Also,
I would have all of them connected. So we are
going to design our products by following the
breakdown of this workflow. So now that we have
outlined our workflow stages, and we have broken
down all of our workflow stages like this, the
next thing we need to do is to start executing
each of the actions that we have outlined here,
one after another. So let's get to work. So the
first stage of our workflow here is the stage
where the stakeholders will present us with the
problem and the user space in the problem, right.
And as you can see, that stage is sorted, because
I assumed that a stakeholder presented us with
this problem and the users facing the problem.
So this stage is sorted. Now over to the next
stage, which is the stage where the stakeholders
will state their expected goals for the project.
And that is sorted also, as you can see here,
I also assumed that the stakeholders has stated
the expected goals to us, which is to research
and help us simplify every task needed to make
a stock investment. Now over to the next stage,
which is the stage where we the UX designers
will get to work. And that is the empathize
stage. And under the empathize stage here, these
are the actions that we need to take. The first
action is to interview the users face to face,
or send out surveys digitally to the users. Now
in this course, since this is a lesson, I can't
show you how to set up a face to face interview.
But I'll show you how to create a digital
survey using Google Forms. So let's do that.
So I would come here in my browser, and I would
open a new tab, then come here, I would click on
this menu icon here so that I can access my Google
Apps out scroll down and out, click on forms here.
And when I do that, I would come here and I would
click on Blank there, then a blank form will be
created for me. Now I'll give this form a title.
I can call it stock app UX survey. And that's its
outcome here also, and I'll give the form a name.
So I can call the form stock up UX survey also,
or you can give it any name at all that you
want to give it. Now the next thing I would
need to do is to have a form description just
to describe what the survey form is all about.
So outcome here, and I'll have this and
it says this survey is carried out by best
technologists. And it is aimed at improving the
experience of users who want to invest in stocks
from an app without having complex steps. Now you
can come up with a better description when you
are doing this in real life. Now after that out,
start passing in the fields that I want the users
to give me a response to, and the first field
out have here will be an email field. I'd like
to collect the email address of everyone that will
take part in the survey. So that's going to be my
first field here. So to collect email addresses
outcome here. I'll click on settings here.
Then I'll expand responses here. You can see
the responses section here, I'll expand it.
Then in front of this collect email addresses
option here, I'll turn on this toggle button,
just like that. And that's sorted. Now when I
come back here, you will see that we have an
email field here, which is going to require
the user to enter their email address here.
And as you can see, there is a red Asterix
there, showing that this is a mandatory field,
which means that anyone taking this survey
must have to enter their email address.
Now let's move over to the next question that
we are going to ask anyone taking the survey?
And that's going to be us asking them to enter
their full name. Yeah. So I would come here,
when I type that in, I would change this from
multiple choice to shut answer just like that,
then I would come here and I would turn on this
toggle button to make this field a required field,
meaning that anyone taking this survey must
have to enter their full name. And that's
sorted. So I would come here and I would click
on the plus sign here to add another question.
Just like that, then this question will be country
of residence. Now, this is important, because
coming from what the stakeholders presented us
as a problem and the user space in the problem,
we could see that the stakeholders are actually
trying to solve a problem for people living in
Nigeria. So it is important to ask anyone taking
the survey from where they reside. So if someone
from Germany takes the survey, by mistake
or happenstance, then it means that when we
are collecting the data from the survey, we are
actually going to ignore that person's imputes.
Because the person is not based in Nigeria. So
that's why it's going to be important to ask
this question. So I would come here and I would
make this required also. Now make sure this is
set to short answer also, then I would come here
and I would click on this button to add another
question. Now this question is going to be
us asking anyone to can be surveyed enter
their age. And this is also important, because
usage of apps, and the experience behind the usage
of apps differs by age range. So I would ask this
question, and I would set this to short answer,
then I would make this a required question. So
I would go ahead and add another question option
here. So that I can ask my next question, which is
going to be us asking whoever is taking the survey
to enter their profession? I would keep this short
answer. And I'll make this required. Then I'll add
another question here. And this question is going
to be us asking, have you invested in stocks from
a mobile app? Now this is going to be a yes or
no answer. And Google Forms automatically suggest
this because I have a question mark at the end of
the question. Now outcome here, and I'll click on
yes as my first option. And I'll click on No as my
second option, and that's going to be fine. Then
I'll come here and now make this is a required
question. Then I'll add another question here,
which is going to be select the goals you always
love to achieve when investing in stocks from a
mobile app. Now, I'll have that in brackets.
Same select more than one. Now outcome here,
and I'll make sure this is a checkbox option. Now
mimicking this checkbox option is because I want
the person taking the survey to select
more than one answer. So I would come here,
I'll type in my first option, which is going
to be invest quickly. My second option will
be found my wallet with more than one option.
The third option will be withdraw my dividends
quickly, the fourth option will be easily access
transaction history. And the final option here
will be to save time. So this is me asking anyone
taking this survey to tell us what they would
love to achieve more when using a mobile app to
invest in stocks. So these are all the options
that they can choose from and from the answers
they select. We the UX designers will understand
what to focus on when designing and what not to
focus on when designing. So I would come here
and I would make this a required question
also. And that's fine. And I'll add another
question here. Which is going to be me asking
anyone taking this survey this question it says
select the frustrations you face when investing
with the app you are currently using to invest
so out also good Give them the option to select
more than one answer here. And I'd have checkboxes
selected here. So the first option here will
be complex and unnecessary graphs, the second
one will be long time to invest. And the third
option will be excessive ambiguity of information.
The fourth option will be on friendly user
interface. And the final option will be difficulty
in funding wallets or accounts. Now, this is us
asking whoever is taking the survey to tell us
the problems that they have with any investment
app that they're currently using. Now from what
they would select here, we the UX designers will
understand the problems to tackle and what to
completely avoid when designing our own investment
up. So outcome here and I would make this a
required question also. And the final question,
or the final request out have in this survey is
to have the person taking the survey to upload
their picture. Now, this is not going to be a
mandatory field, we are going to make it optional
if they like the upload if they like they don't.
So I would come here out, click on the plus sign
that add question. And I'd come here and select
File Upload. Now outcome here, and I'll click on
Continue. And I would come here and I'd say upload
your image. And I would make sure this is not
set to required. That's because I want it to
be optional. And that's fine. So at this stage,
I'd like for us to preview this survey to see
how it will look like when it is sent out to the
people facing the problem. So I would come here,
and I would click on this button here, you can see
where my mouse cursor is on, when I click on it,
I would have a preview of the survey. And this is
it here. It looks okay. So let's come back here.
And let's click on send. When you click on Send,
you'd have this pop up show up here. Now you'd
come here and you'd edit this message,
just in case you want to send this as an
email to whichever person you want to send it
to. So you would come here and you'd say, vest,
technologies there, you put in your own company's
name, best technologies, has invited you to
fill in a survey for UX research, or whatever
you want to say there. And that's fine.
Now this option is only when you want to send
this survey form an email directly to people,
you would come here and you type in their
email address. Let's say you type this in,
you would use comma then type in the next email
and the next email and the next email. Now,
if you don't want to send this as an email, you
have the option of sending this also adds a link.
Now this option will make it possible for you to
put this link up on your social media or send it
through WhatsApp or send it through any other app
to the public so that anyone that stays in Nigeria
can stumble upon the link and take the survey.
Now to do that, come here and click here. When
you click there, you'll see the link here. Now
come here and click on this checkbox that says
shorten URL. When you do that, you'd have a
shorter link. Now you'd come here and just copy
this link. When you copy it, then you can post it
on LinkedIn, you can post it on Twitter, you can
post it anywhere you want to post it, you can send
it to anyone. And when they click on the link,
they will be taken to the survey form for them to
take the survey. Now when they take the survey,
you will be having the option to see the responses
here. All you do is come back to the form,
click on responses and you'd see all of the
responses over here. Currently, I have zero
responses. So what's going to happen is out take
this survey myself, I would take it twice, so that
I would have two responses. And I'll use those two
responses to continue our research process. Now
take note in real life, you'd have more than two
responses. So I'll pause this video here. I would
go ahead and out. Take the survey myself twice. So
I have taken the survey by myself twice. And these
are my responses. As you can see here we have this
field that says who has responded and these are
the emails of the people that have responded and
these are their full names and all of that now,
this summary tab here in the responses section
will just give you a full summary of all the
responses. Now for you to attend to one response
at a time, come here and click on the individual
tab appear. When you do that, then you can come
here and select the individual responses based on
their email addresses. Currently, this email is
and@xyz.com. And, and all of these responses here,
all of these answers are the answers of this
particular user. If you want to see the answer
from any other user, come here and select
that with the email of that user. If I select
chicks@xyz.com, you will see that I would have all
of this show up here. Now, as you can see here,
this is the email of chooks. And this is the full
name of trucks, trucks, EK, and the country and
city of residence is Nigeria, Enugu, the age is
24. The profession is importer. Have you invested
in stocks? Yes. Have you invested in stocks from
a mobile app? Yes. Select the goals you always
love to achieve when investing in stocks from a
mobile app. And Chuck said to invest quickly to
one my wallet with more than one option to easily
access transaction history and to save time.
Now, the next question here is select the
frustrations you face when investing with
the app you are currently using to invest.
And chucks says, long time to invest complex
and unnecessary graphs, excessive ambiguity of
information and non friendly user interface.
Now, for the other user, which is n, you can see
the email of the user here and the name of the
user is M for lucky. And the country and city of
residence is Nigeria Lagos. I know in my initial
survey form, I did not include city of residence,
actually. But I just had to include that so that I
can target the particular location where the user
is staying. And the age is 24. The professional is
mural artist. Have you invested in stocks? Yes.
Have you invested in stocks from a mobile app?
Yes, select the goals you always love to achieve
when investing in stocks from a mobile app and MCs
to invest quickly to find my wallet with more than
one option is the access transaction history save
time and for this question here and select long
time to invest complex and unnecessary graphs,
excessive ambiguity of information and non
friendly user interface. Now at the bottom here,
you would also see that the date of submission
and the time of submission is recorded. So I'll
come back here. And I'd also like to let you
know that you can, you can export this response
to a spreadsheet. Now, I would advise you that if
you want to do that, come here, click on summary,
then click on create spreadsheets. When you
do that, you'd have this option to select,
create a new spreadsheet or select existing
spreadsheets. Now, if this is your first time,
just create a new spreadsheet. Now I'll keep that
now out, keep that selected, come here and out,
click on Create. When I do that, I'll have a
new tab launched. And as you can see, all of my
responses has been exported into the spreadsheets.
Now you can also choose to come here and make your
analysis from the spreadsheets. And that's okay.
So after you create your surveys and send them out
and the users or the people that you sent them
out to send in their responses, you would go ahead
to create what we call user personas for each
and every user that sent in a response. So at
this stage, I'd like us to see how to create user
personas and take notes. Creating user personas is
an action you take while you're at the empathize
stage. Now just understand that this empathize
stage is the stage where you get to know the users
better and understand their frustrations better.
And that's because it's only when you understand a
problem better that you can come up with a better
solution for that problem. So let's go ahead and
let's see how to create user personas for each
of the user that sent in a response to our survey.
So I would come here now. And I would select the
text tool here. And I'd have this here, I would
say user personas, I would keep that selected.
I'll change this text from a normal text to a sub
heading text. And I'd make this bold, then I would
come here and I'll change the color of this text
to that. So this is going to be our user persona
section. Let's duplicate this. Let's come up here.
Let's call this section, workflow break down.
However you want to call it, it's fine. That's
okay. So I'll just scroll down to the user persona
section. And the first thing I'd have here is
the image of the user that I want to create a
persona for. So I would come here, I would select
the square tool here to have a square shape here,
which I am going to use to place the image of
that user in. Now this is necessary, whether the
user sends in an image or not, you can just have
these here, if the user does not send in an image,
then you leave this blank, go ahead and do
the rest. But if the user sends in an image,
then you place the image in here.
Now there's one way to place an image
into a shape here in feature, all you have to do
is keep the shape selected, right click on it,
then go to plugins and use the Unsplash
plugins for that. So I would come here,
I would launch that plugin. And I would come in
here and I'll type in African woman. So I can have
an image of an African woman show up there. So I'd
come here and out select this. And that's okay.
So the next thing to do is to have all of these
details about this person who has this image.
Now the name here is an felucca, the country
and city is Nigeria, Lagos the age is 24
Professional mural artists. Now, over
here, I would say an is a mural artist
resident in Lagos, Nigeria, and is also a stock
investor who invests in stocks with existing stock
investing apps in Nigeria. And this is like his
summary about her personality. Now, I'll go ahead
and out highlight her frustrations with the
existing investment apps that she used in Nigeria
and out also highlights the goals that she aims to
achieve with an investment app. So outcome here,
now have this here, outpaced this. And over here,
these are the things that she wishes that she had
as an experience with an investment app. And these
are her current frustrations. Now all of these
details about an was gotten from the response
that she gave us when she took this survey that
we created. So you can see how this connects. So
let's go ahead and let's create a user persona for
the other user that took the survey. So that
is going to be chooks. So I would come here,
I would have this shape here. And I would run the
Unsplash plugin on that shape. And I would type in
African man. And I would go with this here. And
that's okay. So I would have this hair for chooks.
This is his name, and his country and city, age,
profession, and all of that out also highlight
his goals and frustrations. And that's fine
still. So what we have done so far is this,
we have concluded the empathize stage, we
have gotten to know about the problem from
the perspective of the users. And we have created
user personas for each user that took our survey.
So we are going to move ahead to the next stage
of our workflow here, which is the stage where we
are going to create a problem statement based on
all we have gathered during the empathize stage.
Now this really makes sense because you can
create a better problem statement when you
understand the problem better. And the way to
understand the problem better is to empathize
with the people facing the problem. And that's
what we have done. So let's go ahead and let's
create a problem statement based on what we have
learned. So I'll duplicate this outcome here,
I'd say problem statements. And for me going by
all we have learned from the empathize stage,
this is my problem statement. My problem
statement states that users are frustrated with
existing investment apps, as a result of excessive
ambiguity of information and complex steps. These
consents negatively affect the experience of these
users. Now, this is my problem statements and
this is the problem that our try solve. So, if we
come up here, you will see that we have empathized
with the users and we have created a problem
statement. So the next stage of our workflow is
the idea stage, which is the stage where we
have to come up with an idea that can solve the
problems that we have in the problem statement
and what actions are we to take at this stage.
So at the idea stage, the first thing we are
going to do is to set up a brainstorming session
where we are going to invite other designers,
product managers, business managers Lawyers,
software engineers, and so on and so forth.
Now, when we invite all of these people, we
are going to present them with enough information
about the problems in the problem statement, and
ask them to come up with ideas that can possibly
solve the problems in the problem statement. Now,
when each and every one of these people
that we have invited, come up with an idea,
the next thing to do is to read out all of these
ideas to everyone and call a vote for the best
idea. Now, the idea with the highest votes should
be selected. And when that is done, it means that
you are ready to move to the next stage of our
workflow, which is the stage where you'd have
to design that idea into a testable prototype. So
before we move over to this stage here, I'd like
to come here out also highlights that this stage
is the idea stage. This is the idea stage. And
since this is going to be a brainstorming
session stage, and obviously I can't have
a brainstorming session here in this lesson,
it's going to be something that you'd set up
with the people you want to set it up with, beat
on Zoom discord, beat real life, anyhow, you want
to set it up, that's fine. So I'll just highlight
this stage here. And what I'm going to do is,
I would assume that I conducted a brainstorming
session offline, just so that we can learn better.
And I'd also assume that during that brainstorming
session, we arrived at an idea. So I'd have this
here selected idea. And I would paste this as our
selected idea. Now this is the selected idea for
this course, it says Create an investment app
where graphs are represented with text, where
users will have the option to fund the account
and wallet via bank transfer or their debit cards,
where recent transaction history will be easily
accessible. And were plain and easy to understand
English will be mostly used. Now if you
look at this idea, you'd see that this idea
solves the problems that we have in this problem
statements. And this problem statement was gotten
from all we learned during the empathize stage.
And we were able to learn all we learned during
this stage because we created a survey form and
sent out the survey to use us so you can see how
everything connects. So now that we have an idea
that we can use to solve the problem, the next
stage here is the design prototype stage. And at
this stage, the actions that we need to take all
of these First things first, we need to create an
information architecture for this best idea that
was selected during the idea stage. So I would
come here, I would scroll down to this point.
And I would have this here, I'd say information
architecture. Now before we create the information
architecture, let's understand what an information
architecture is and why it is important
to create one. So the information architecture of
a mobile app is the way you organize and arrange
information on the mobile app that will help the
users have that mobile app to accomplish their
task on that mobile app without a bad experience.
So it is in the information architecture,
that you will decide what features and what
information we exist on each page of the app,
and each step of the app. So let's go ahead.
And let's create an information architecture
for this idea. Now, the way to start creating
your information architecture is to first of all,
define the goals of the users who will use
the app, then define the task that the users
have to complete to achieve their goals on the
app. So outcome here, and I'd have this here.
So this here is the goal of the user to invest
with a good experience. Now the user task here
are the actions that the user will have to take
to achieve this goal. Now, what are the task,
the user will have to sign up to the application
as a new user or log in as an existing user
then fund their account or their wallet, then use
the fund that they have in their account or wallet
to invest in any stock of their choice. So
if they can accomplish this task, this task
and this task, it means that they have achieved
that goal on that app. So after defining the
goals of the user and stating the task that
the user has to complete to achieve that goal,
we are going to go ahead to create our information
architecture flow, and for the sake of time out,
speed up this process, and I'll explain it so that
you can understand. So what we have here is our
information architecture flow. And our zoom in so
that I can break down this flow one after another
and also show you how to come up with a flow like
this. This is the start point of the flow. This is
where the user launches the app. So when the user
launches the app, the user will have two options,
one to sign up and want to log in. So let's go
with the signup flow here. Now, if the user is
trying to sign up, the user will be required to
sign up with their email address, phone number
and password. And after this step, the user will
have to verify their phone number. Now, after the
phone number is verified, the user will be taken
to the homepage of the application. When the user
gets to the homepage of the application, the user
will have all of these options here. And the first
route or the first option here will be the menu
icon, which will be on the homepage. The user will
also have the account balance displayed on the
homepage, the user will have a fund account option
that they can use to fund the account still on the
homepage. And still on the homepage. The recent
transactions by the user will be displayed there
on the homepage. Now, still, on the homepage,
we are going to have a referral banner. Still on
the homepage, we are going to have an invest route
that the users can take if they wish to invest in
stocks. Now still, on the homepage, we are going
to have a transact option, just in case the user
wishes to deposit or withdraw. So all of this is
on the homepage. Now let's look at the flow of the
first item here, which is the Menu icon. Now if
the user clicks on the menu icon, which is on the
homepage, the user will see all of these options,
recent transactions, card management, investment
portfolio request statements and settings. Now,
just for the sake of those who don't know what a
menu icon is, if you go to an app or a website,
using your mobile phone, you would always have
this icon here at the top that when you click on
it, you'd have a drop down or you'd have a menu
bar sliding from the left or from the right now,
that's what we call the Menu icon. And most mobile
apps have that. So this is going to be all that we
show up when the user accesses the menu icon route
now for the account balance, or that's going to
show a base available balance. And that's all. Now
for the fund accounts option. This is the flow,
the user will have to choose a method. And
this is important for the experience. Because
from our user research, it was clear to us
that the users actually want an experience
where they would have the option to fund their
account with more than one option. So when they
choose a method, then they would go ahead to
find the account with that method that they have
chosen. So that's what the fund accounts route
right now for the recent transactions route.
All the user will have when they access a recent
transaction will be the transaction details.
And that's okay. Now we have the referral banner
option here. And when the user access the routes,
they would have a referral promo code that they
can copy you know and send to a friend to join
the app for all of that and all of that. And
that's fine. Now we have the InVEST route here.
When a user accesses this route, the user will
see a list of stocks that they can invest in
and will also see their stock portfolio that they
had invested in. So if the user access one of the
stocks that's been listed, the user will see the
detail for that stock. And if they like what they
see in the detail, they will go ahead to invest.
And that's a good flow. So if you come here,
we have this route here, which is the transact
route. When the user accesses this route,
the user will have the option to make a deposit,
which is also like funding the account you get.
And the user will also have the option to make
a withdrawal from the account. So this is just
the basic information architecture flow for this
app. And it is always important for you to create
this information architecture, so that you will
understand and organize the steps that the user
will take on the app. It is also important so that
you can also streamline the core features that
each page Your app will have. Now if you remember,
that was the signup proud, the login routes is
still the same, because all you have to do here
to login is just enter your email address and your
password, then you'll be taken to the homepage.
Still, when you get to the homepage, every other
theme is the same. So that's that if you have any
questions on the information architecture here,
draw my attention to it. And I'm there to help.
So if you come here now, in our flow breakdown,
you'd see that under the design prototype stage,
we have created our information architecture.
The next action at this stage is to create a low
fidelity prototype of the best idea using the
information architecture. Now before we do that,
I'd love to explain what a low fidelity prototype
is. So a low fidelity prototype is a dummy
version of your final design for an app. Now,
the question you may ask is this, why do we
need to design a dummy version? Now this is it.
Designing a dummy version is important because
at this stage of trying to figure everything out,
your design, and your design process can be
subject to lots of changes, and imputes from the
stakeholders. Now, it's just like building a dummy
house first, before you build the main house. Now,
if you use paper to build a dummy house first,
before building the main house, it's going to be
a lot easier when the owner of the house comes
to make a correction or comes to make a change.
Since it's a paper, you don't have much to lose,
all you have to do is just tear it and put it
back in seconds. But if you go ahead to build the
main house first, and the owner of the house comes
and says, Okay, I don't want this design here, I
don't want that there, it means that you'd have to
break down that part of the house and rebuild that
part of the house with all of the resources that
you have put into building that part of the house.
And that's going to be a lot more hectic compared
to you using a paper to just build a prototype
or a model of the house. So that's basically
what a low fidelity prototype is. And that's why
it is important for you to have a low fidelity
prototype, then take that to the stakeholders
for correction and changes and imputes and all
of that. Now, when the low fidelity prototype has
been accepted and agreed on, then you can go ahead
to design the real app itself, which is the high
fidelity prototype. So let's go ahead and let's
see how to create a low fidelity prototype of
our best idea. So we are going to do that using
a figma design file. So I would come here, I would
go to figma. And I'll create a new design file.
And I'll call this stock investment app. And out
come here and out, rename the page one to low
fidelity. And this page is going to contain all
our low fidelity screens. So let's go ahead and
let's start. So to design low fidelity screens
is easy. And it is easy because you don't need
a design system for that. Like you don't need
a style library. To do that. You don't need a
component library. To do that. You don't need
all of that, all you have to do is focus on the
user task. So if you come here, you'd see that
our user task on this app is to sign up a login
on your account or wallet and invest. And if
a user accomplish all of these tasks, it means
that the user will achieve their goal on this app,
which is to invest in stocks. So we are going to
design a low fidelity screams around these user
task. So let's come back here and I've picked
my design file. And let's see what it is to create
low fidelity screams, all you have to do is select
the frame tool, then go with any template of
your choice, I would go with iPhone 13 Promax,
and not have that. So the next thing I'll do
is to just come here. And since this is going
to be the splash screen, I'll just have this
logo stay here out align it to the center,
horizontally and to the center vertically, then
I would go ahead to create the login screen,
the signup screen and all of that. And actually,
the way I like doing it is this, I like to segment
the screams into categories using the user
task. This section or this segment should
be four authentication screens. So I'll go ahead,
speed up this process and have other screens here.
Then I'll explain how I came about all of that.
Now before I do that, I may have missed something
here. I know some people who are new to fit
jam may not understand how these connectors are
created. Now all you have to do is use the
connector to select it, click on the point, then
you connect it anyhow, you want to connect
it, you can take your connector anywhere,
connect any shape that you are trying
to connect, and that's fine. And when
your connector is created, you can actually play
around with it, you can click on it to select it,
grab the points, take it up, take it down, anyhow,
you want to play around with it, it's fine.
Now you can also select the connector and change
the color of the connector, just like this. So all
of these connection lines were created using the
connector tool here. So let's go back to our figma
design file. And out pause this video here and
come back with all of our low fidelity screams,
then I'll explain further. So what we have here
are low fidelity screens for the authentication
task. So let's zoom in. As you can see, here,
we have the splash screen, which is this. Now
after the splash screen, we have this screen where
the user will have to choose that authentication
action, which is either to login or to sign up.
Now to create this button here, you don't need to
use an auto layout or any of that, all you just
have to do is select the rectangle to like this
created anyhow, you want to create it, then come
here, select the text to and you can just say
login or sign up or whatever you want to have.
They're just like this. That's how I created
this. And I did not have to come up with a color.
And it's advisable for you not to use colors when
creating your low fidelity screams. And that's
because if you have colors chosen, it may distract
the stakeholders when you are presenting the
low fidelity screams to them at this stage,
all you should focus on is the user experience.
So having colors or making the low fidelity
screams look good, may distract the stakeholders
away from the user experience. So that's how I
came up with the buttons there. And here also,
this impute fields, I just use the rectangle,
the rectangle to create a rectangle shape there,
I added a stroke. And I took out the field color
and I had that then I had a text inside there
saying email just like that. And this button,
we know how to do that. I duplicated all of
this. And I had one more field here for the phone
number. And my button is still here. Then here we
have this field for a verification code. And over
here I have the Verify button that Okay, so all
of the screens here are for the authentication
task. Now let's scroll down to the next task,
which is going to be the fund wallets task. And
that task actually will happen from the
homepage. So that's why I created a low fidelity
version of our homepage. So you can
see that we don't have too much of
information here. So if I scroll down, you'll see
that I have the fund accounts pop up action here.
Now this element is going to show up when a user
clicks on fund accounts here. When they do that,
this pop up will show up for them to choose the
method that they want to fund the account with.
And that's okay, so this is easy to create,
just have a rectangle like this and have your
text inside of it. Then the background of
this navigation section is also a rectangle
that I had across the screen like this, and
I changed the color to something like this,
just like that. That's easy. So over here, this is
a rectangle also with a text on it. And I have a
rectangle here with a corner radius of 16 px. And
that's okay here, we know how to create a button.
And this is just text. Now for this icon here, I
got that from an icon plugin, I used the feather
icons plugin to have that sorted. So this task is
complete, we have the font accounts button here,
which if a user clicks on it, you will have this
pop up show up like this. Now let's move over to
the next task on our app. And the next task here
is to invest. So if I come here, and I scroll
down, you'll see that I have this screens for the
InVEST task. Now this is the section for that we
have this page here we have this icon we have this
text here. Now I have this section which is like
the list of stocks to invest in. I have this
search bar here. I have this search field here
which is also easy to create. All you have to do
is create a rectangle give it a corner reduce of
let's say 16 Or let's say 816 is a lot. Then come
here take out the the fill color and give it a
stroke Hello, and you have that, then you have a
text inside there, that's really easy to create,
then I have the list of stocks here. So I just
have a rectangle here also with this text on top
of it. So it's also easy to create, all you
have to do is just have something like this,
then give it a canary use of 16, then take the
color down the beats to this point, then have
your text written on top of its plot away, then
keep this here, then have this plus 234 percent.
They're all any number that you're okay with. So
that's how I created this. And if you scroll down,
you'll see that we have the your stock portfolio
section, which has this also, we know how to
create this. And over here we have the navigation
section. And that's okay. So the next page here,
let's zoom out a bit. The next page here is the
stock Details page. Now, this is all assuming that
a user is interested in this stock here, you can
see where my mouse cursor is on. So if a user is
interested in this stock, and the user goes ahead
to click on it, this details page will show up
for the stock showing the details of that stock
and the company that owns the stock, you'd have
the company logo here. And you'd have the stock
percentage and all of that there, you'd have the
interest for that stock, minimum cap volume, about
the company, the valuation rank and all of that,
then you'd have an invest button here. And I think
by now we know how to create all of the elements
here. Now, if a user clicks on the InVEST button,
they would go to this page where they would have
to enter the amounts that they wish to invest in
that stocks with. And I believe on this page here,
we know how to create all of the elements
that we have here. Now, if a user clicks on
the next button here, after entering, the amount
they wish to invest in that stocks with the user
will be taken to the next page here, which is
going to display the summary of the investments
they're about to make. Over here, they would have
the amount that they typed in here, display here,
the minimum cap, the interest value, and so many
other details, and so many other details that are
not listed here. Now, if the user is okay with
that, the user clicks on the Proceed button, and
the next page that user will be taken to is the
success page indicating that that investment
is successful. Now the user will have the option
to click on the back to home button here. And
that's that it means that that task, which is
the Invest task has been successful. So for us
to properly present low fidelity screens like this
for testing and for impute and for opinions. And
for all of that. For us to properly do that, it
means that we need to make a prototype of this
low fidelity screens, so that we can present
them properly for testing and for imputes from
the stakeholders. So let's go ahead and let's do
that. I'll click on the prototype option here.
So let's start with the splash screen. So
out select out, click on the splash screen
to select it. When the splash screen is selected,
you'd have this point here, all you have to do is
click on it, hold it and drag it to the screen
of destination. So I would want the users to go
from the splash screen to this screen here. Now
when I connect this splash screen to this other
screen here, you'll see that figma will bring up
this interaction details card for us. So that we
can set the mode of our interaction. So over
here I have the On Click event. And the action
for that onclick event is a navigate to action. So
what this means is that when the splash screen is
clicked, we are going to navigate to this screen
here, which is iPhone that in Promax two, this
is the name here actually, you can actually it is
advisable for you to rename all of your screens,
that's the best way to do it. So this practically
means when the splash screen is clicked on,
navigate to this other screen, which is this one
here. Now we have an animation section here that
we can set the animation of that transition
or the animation of that navigation. So
currently to set instance, I can come
here and set this to smart animate,
then set this to ease in and out and out. Set
the animation delay time to 800 milliseconds,
just type in 800 there and press the Enter key on
your keyboard and figma will add the milliseconds
for you. Now this animation settings is optional.
The most important thing here is that we have set
the event and the action that will be triggered by
that event, then we have sets to destination frame
for that action. And that's okay. So that's
sorted. Now outcome here, out, click on this
button. And I will say, okay, when a user clicks
on this login button, they should go to the login
screen, which is this. Now for the Interaction
Details, ugly with set like this. This is the
setting we had before now. So I'll leave it set
like that. Now, for the sign up button. When a
user clicks on the sign up button, it means the
user is a new user. So I would like that user
to be taken to the signup page, which is this one
here. Now, when the user goes to the login page,
and the user enters their email and their
password, it means that they would have to
click on the login button. And when they click on
the login button, I'd like them to go straight to
the home page, which is this. Now remember,
for a user to log in, it means the user is an
existing user. Now, when a user selects the Sign
Up option here, it means the user is a new user,
and the user will have to enter their email
address, phone number and password right.
Now when they do that, it means they would have
to have their phone number verified first. So
when the user clicks on sign up, the user
will be taken to the verification code page.
And when the user's phone number is verified,
the user will then be taken to the homepage. And
that's fine. So you have seen that we have created
the authentication flow. So let's come over here
on the homepage, let's work on the next task.
Now the next task is to fund the accounts, right.
And to fund the accounts, the user will have
to click on the fund accounts button. Now when
they do that, we are going to want a pop up to
show up on the screen. And that pop up should
show this card here that will that will require
the user to choose the method that they want to
fund their accounts with. Let's come here in
our Interaction Details. Over here, it's an
On Click event. That's okay. Now, over here, we
have the Navigate to option. And that's not what
we want, we want a popup to show up on that same
screen, we don't want the user to leave that page
that the user is on, we want the user to still
stay on that page, but have a pop up show up. So
how do we make that happen, we are going to
change this from navigates to to open overlay.
When we change it to open overlay, we are going to
come here and select the center option, because I
would want this pop up to stay at the center of
the screen here. So over here, I would keep this
selected, which is closed when clicking outside
and out. Also keep this add background behind
overlay options selected, then for the opacity of
the background overlay out, keep it set to 25%.
Now for the animation, you can still keep it set
instance or come here and select any other option
of your choice. So that's okay. And we are okay
with that. Now, if a user selects bank transfer
or debit card, they will be taken to another page
where they would have to process that transaction
method. So you can also come here, if you don't
mind, let's click on Design, you can come here and
duplicate this page and and create a low fidelity
screen for that you can call these bank transfer.
And you can have whichever element you want
to have here. And you can go ahead to have
the debit card page also that the user will go
to when they select the debit card option here.
But that's not the point here. So I'll take
this out. Now we are done with the fund wallet
task. So the next task is the Invest task.
And this task will happen from the homepage.
It is when the users go to the homepage, that
they would click on this invest option here for
them to go to the InVEST page so that they can
invest in stocks. So from this homepage here,
outcome held click on prototype. From this
homepage here, I would select this invest button
here. And I'll create a connection to this page.
And that's okay. So when a user clicks on that
invest button at the navigation section there on
the homepage, that user will be taken to this page
here, which is the Invest page where the user will
see the list of stocks that they can invest in and
their stock portfolio. So if a user comes to this
invest page, the task we want them to complete
is to invest So let's say the user is cool with
this stock here and the user wishes to invest
in this stock, I would select it,
then I would create a connection
like this. This means that when the user clicks on
this stock, the user will go to the stock details
page for that stock. And when the user is okay
with that stock details that the user sees here,
the user will click on the InVEST button here.
And the user will go here to this other page,
where the user will have to enter the amount
that they wish to invest in that stocks with.
And when the user enters the amount they
wish to invest with, the user will click on
the Next button, which will take the user to
this page here where the user will see a summary
of the investment the user is about to make. And
when the user is okay with all the user sees here,
the user will click on proceed and
the investment, which is the task
will be completed. So what we have here is we
are done creating a low fidelity screens. And
we can present a low fidelity screens for testing
now. So how do we do that, I would come here,
I would select the splash screen, because that's
where the whole journey starts from right? When I
select it, I would come here, and I would click on
this presents button here to have that presented,
a new tab will be launched for that. So I would
come here, and I would click on the Enter full
screen option here you can see where my mouse
cursor is on. Now, this is the presentation,
I would present to the stakeholders, which are
my employers or the owners of the app. So I will
take this presentation to them to demonstrate the
user experience that I have come up with that will
enable the users to accomplish their task on this
app. So I would go from here, I would click on
this screen. And I'll explain to the stakeholders
at this point that existing users can click on
login. And new users can click on sign up. So I
would demonstrate these as a new user, I would say
okay, when they click on sign up, they would come
here enter their email, phone number and password.
When they click on the Sign up button, they would
have to enter a verification code. And when they
are verified, they would go to the homepage. Now,
if they want to invest, it means they have to fund
the account. So I would click on the fund account
button to demonstrate to them that in this case,
now we have a bank transfer method and debit card
method, I would say okay, if the users go ahead
to fund to fund the accounts, then it means the
users are ready to invest. So for them to invest,
they would come down here and click on the InVEST
button there. When we use that those that the user
will see list of stocks that they can invest in.
And if the user chooses to invest in any of the
stock, let's use this, for example, they would
click on it, when they click on it, the user
will be taken to the stock details page for that
stock. And when the user is satisfied with the
details of the stock, the user will click on the
InVEST button here, then the user will be required
to enter the amount they wish to invest in that
stocks with when the user does that, the user will
click on the Next button here. And when the user
clicks on that next button, the user will see a
summary of the investment they are about to make.
And if the user is satisfied, the user clicks on
the Proceed button here and the investment
will be successful. And when the user is done,
the user clicks on back to home, and the user will
be taken back to the homepage. So a presentation
like this will really reveal the experience that
the user will have using this product. So if
your low fidelity prototype has been accepted
by the stakeholders, it means that it is now
time for you to go ahead and start the process of
designing your high fidelity prototype, which is
going to be like the real design version of your
app, or the final design version of your app.
And it is at that stage that you'd focus on themes
like colors, typography, effects, components,
library style library, and all of that. So in
this course, let's assume that our stakeholders
gave us a pass for these low fidelity screams
and they are okay with it. Let's assume that our
stakeholders now want us to go ahead to design the
real version of the app. So what do we do? Let's
click on Design. Come here. Create a new page
and call this Hi Fi deleting. So at this stage,
I'd like to welcome everyone to the most
interesting part, which is the part where we
start building our designs from scratch. So
first things first, I'll go ahead to create
my style library. And I will start by creating
my typography styles. So I will do that using
the Material Design version to guide. So I
would come over here, I would go to material.io.
And when I come here out, click on Design. When I
click on Design out, come here on the left side,
and I'll click on typography, then I would select
the type system. And when I do that, I would come
here. So the first thing that I would have set
is the typeface or font family that I want to use
for this project. For this project, I would love
to use the rubric font family. So I would come
here, and I would select it here for headlines
and subtitles, then I would go ahead to select
it here for body and captions, just like that.
Now I'll use the data here in this type scale
to create my typography styles. Now let's start
with creating headline textiles for this project.
Now since this is a mobile app project, I
won't see the need to have a headline one text,
same for the headline to text. So I would go
with the headline for textile as my own headline
one textile just because this is a mobile app
design and this size of text is going to look
too big for a mobile app. So I would come here
out click on headline for and I would use these
details here. So I would come here I'll create a
frame here where my textiles are going to stay in
so I would say headline one a duplicate this
out say headline one bold. So outloud say
headline two now this is me getting everything
set before I start applying the details that
out get here from the type scale generator. So
outcome here out, duplicate this and out see
headline to bold and out come here out have this
out see a headline three. And this is going to
be headline three bold, and that's going to be
that for my headline textiles for this project.
Now I'll go ahead to have my body textiles. So I
would come here out, prepare this for body large.
And I'd have this be a body large
bold textile, then I would go with
body small here. And I'd have this as Bodhi small
bald. Now this is my own style. And this is my own
pattern. I am not saying this is the standard out
there. I'm just doing this because this is what I
feel will give me the best design. Now come here.
This will be for my button text and I'll have a
caption text. So after having all of this set out,
come here out select the headline one text here.
And I will use the headline for textile here in
material design. Just like I said I would use this
for my headline one textile. So the font family
sets Rubik, the width is set to Normal, which is
regular, the size is set to 35. And the letter
spacing is set to 0.25 px. So I would go ahead and
I would have all of these sets. So I would come
here keep this selected, how to set this to Rubik
and how to set this to regular and for the letter
spacing out come here and out set this to 0.25 px,
and for the size out set it to 35 px. Now I'll use
these same settings for this headline one text for
the headline, one bold text, the only difference
will be that this is going to be a bold text and
this is going to be a regular text. So I
would select this. Now to set this to 35.
I would set this to beak and I'll keep it set
to bold like I said, and I'll make this 0.25 px
and that's okay, so I'll go ahead and now do
same for headline to headline three body large
body large bowed down to the caption text. Now
for the headline to text here, I would come here
in material design and I would use the headline
five textile for my own headline to textile. So
the font families Rubik, the weight is normal,
the size is 24. So I would set the size to 24.
And for the weights out, keep it set regular
and for the font family. I'll keep it set to
Rubik. Now the letters business zero px, so I
can just keep it set at 0% or just come in here
and type in zero px, and that's fine. I would
use the same setting for the headline to bold,
but the difference will be that this is going to
be a bold text So I would come here, I would set
this to 24. Send this to Rubik. Keep this set
to zero, keep the letter spacing set to zero,
and then keep this sets bold. So I can have that.
Now for my headline three text. If I come here,
I'll use the headline six textile here for my own
headline pre text. So I would keep this set Rubik,
this set to medium size set to 20. So I'll keep
the size set to 20. And for this, I'll keep it
set to medium and outside this to Rubik. Then for
the letter spacing, it sets 0.15 px. So I would
come here, I would say 0.15 px. And that's going
to be cool. Then for the headline three bold,
I would have the same sentence there. But
the only difference as usual will be that
this is going to be a bold text. So I would come
in here, outside this to rubik cube assets board.
And for the size, I think it's 20 px, and for the
letter spacing is 0.15 px. So I'll type that in.
And I'll keep this set to 20 Just like this.
And that's okay. So for the body large text,
come here and use the body one textile
here, you can see that the size is 16 px,
the width is normal, and the letter spacing is 0.5
px. So I'd come here, keep this here, I would set
the letter spacing to 0.5 px outsets, the
weights to regular and outset these to 16. And
out set this to Rubik and that's okay, for the
body large board, you know what to do already,
how to set this to 16, set these to 0.5 px,
set this to bold, then set this to Rubik.
And that's it. So I'll go ahead and out, have
my body small text here. And if I come here and
material design out, use the body to textile here
material design for that. So I'll keep it set to
normal set the size to 14 and the letter spacing
to 0.25 px. So I would have this set to 0.25 px,
I'd set this to 14, out set this to Rubik, and
I'd set this to regular. So I'd have this here.
And this is going to be 14 0.25. And this
is going to be Rubik. And that's sorted.
Now for the button text. I'll keep this here. If
you come here, you'd see that the button text here
has a size of 14 px and a letter spacing value of
1.25 px with a weight that is set to medium. Now,
over here, material design to the button
text is all in uppercase. But in my case,
I won't have my text stay in uppercase. And
I think in material design version three,
the button text is not represented in uppercase.
So I would go ahead and I'd have this set of 14.
And the letter spacing is pretty big.
So I would have that set to 1.25 px. And
this will be set to medium with the font family
sets to Rubik. And that's what we have here.
Now for the caption text, it's going to be
set to 12 px with a letter spacing value
of zero points for PX and a normal weight.
So I would come here, I'll keep this here.
And now I have this sets regular, this will be
0.4 px. And this will be set to 12 Just like this.
And the font family will be set Rubik. So this
is going to be a caption text. So at this stage,
what I'll do is I'll go ahead to save
all of these styles that I have created
to my style library. And I think we all
know how to do that by now. So I would
speed this process up, I would select this column
here, and I would call this headline one out go
ahead fast forward this part of the course and
come back. So this is it, I have created and saved
the textile that I would need for this project.
So I would come here and I would rename this frame
typography styles, just for better documentation,
you know, now when I click on my empty canvas,
you would see that I have all of my saved textiles
over here. Now let's go ahead and let's create a
color styles out. We'll name this frame to color
styles. I'd save that now out create my color
styles based on my meat. I want to make use of the
Material Design Guide to create my color styles.
And that's because you can actually do that. You
can create your color styles your textiles you
can create any of your styles without using the
Material Design Guide And you can actually mix it,
you can create your textiles with the Material
Design Guide and have your color styles created
from your own inspiration. So outcome here,
I'd like to have a background color here.
So I'll use this my background color, or have a
text stay at the top here to indicate that this is
for my background color, I would select this text
and I would make use of one of my saved textiles.
So I'll go with the body large text there. So
for my background color style, I'd like to use
this color. And that's good. Let's zoom into
this point. So we can see clearly, and after
having a background color, I'll duplicate this use
this here, I would love to have a surface color.
And for my surface color, I'd like it to be this
color here, you can use any color of your choice,
this is my own choice. So I'll duplicate
this, and have this day here. And this time,
I'd like to have a surface text column, you
can call this an on surface color, actually.
So I'd like to have a surface text color, which
is going to be the color that I'll use to write
text on the surface color. So I'd like this to be
white. Actually, I know this may not be visible.
But I'd like that to be whites just like that. So
I would duplicate this. Now for us to make this
visible out, select it and add a shadow effect.
The next color that out heavier, we called the off
text column. And that's my own choice, I'd like
to have another color for my text. So I would use
this shade for my off text color. And duplicate
this. And I'd have another color here, which is
going to be my error column. And obviously,
this is going to be a red color. So I'll use
this shade of red for that, then I'd have this
here. And I'd like to have a second surface color.
And I'd like that color to be just like this.
And that's fine. So I have selected all of the
color styles that I would want for this project.
So I would go ahead and I would save all of these
styles to my style library. And I think we all
know how to do that. So I would select this column
here. And I'd call that background color, I would
speed up this process and I would come back to it.
So as you can see, I am done creating and saving
my color styles. And these are my color styles
here. So that's sorted. The next thing I'd like
us to do is to go ahead and create the grid style
that we are going to use for this project. So to
do that, I would use a mobile layout, I would use
the iPhone pattern Promax layout, so I would have
the iPhone 10 Promax layout here, I would rename
it to mobile grid style out zooming to this point,
I'll keep it selected, then I'll add a layout grid
property to it, just like that, then I'd have this
big column grid. Now I have the count before I
would have the margin be 16 out have the gotta be
16. And for the color out go with something like
this. Now, we are sorted for the column grid. So I
would go ahead and add a row grid property to it.
I'll keep it selected still come here. Now
to add another grid property that outset,
as a row grid property, just like this out,
set the count to 800. And out set the stretch
to center out set the gutter property to zero
out come here, I will set the height property
to eight. And that's because I want the space
between the row lines to be eight px, then outcome
here now change the color something like this.
And that's going to be okay for me. So I would
keep this selected. Come here. And I'll save this
grid style as my grid style for this project. So
I'll click on style there. And I'll call this
mobile grid style. You can call it whatever you
want to call it. Now we have three styles saved to
our style library, we have our textiles, we have
our color styles, and we have agreed styles. So
I would like for us to go ahead and create shadow
styles for this project. To do that, I would
come here out have a frame here. Then I would
rename this to shadow styles, when I renamed
that to shadow Stiles out have some rectangles
right inside that frame. And the rectangle is just
to display the shadow effects and how it's going
to look like. So I'll keep that selected. I'll
make the corner radius to have a value of eight.
I'll give it this column. And I'll duplicate
this and have this here. I'll just have three
shadow effect styles. So I'll keep that there
and outcome here in material design. Now,
go to the homepage out, click on the Search icon
there and I'll type in shadow. When I press the
enter key out, have these results show up. So I
would come here, I would click on this link here,
that's going to take me to material design version
one, bear out make use of the recommendations that
they have there for creating shadow styles.
So I would click on that link. Now come here,
and I would use this shadow recommendations that's
under the sketch section. So I want to go with the
one DP elevation table here, I'll scroll down,
and I'll make use of the 16 DP elevation table.
So I'll use these values here to create my shadow
styles. So I'll create a key shadow and an ambient
shadow. Now on that key shadow, you can see that
we have two types of key shadow styles. We have
the Umbra key shadow style and the penumbra key
shadow style. So I'll create an ombre key shadow
style first, and for that the Opacity value is
set to 14. So I would come out keep this selected,
I would add an effect property, and I would set
the Opacity value here to 14, and the X property
is set to zero with the Y property set to 16.
So outcome here for the Y property out set this
to 16, the X property has already set to zero. Now
the block properties 24, and the spread properties
too. So for the block property out, set it to
24. And for the spread property out set it to.
And here we have our umbrella key shadow effect.
So I would go ahead and create for the panel,
Brad key shadow effect and the MPs shadow effects.
So I would speed up this process also, and I'll
come back when I'm done. So these are the shadow
styles that I have created. So I'll go ahead and
out, save them to my style library, the way to do
that is pretty easy. Select this rectangle there,
then come here in the Effects section, click
on that style icon there. And you can call this
whatever you want to call it out call this
light shadow out cold this other one here,
mid shadow, and out cold this peak shadow and
that's okay. So far, I have my textiles created,
I have my color styles created, I have my effects
styles created and I have my grid styles created.
Now at this stage, we are ready to start designing
the components for our app. So I would like us
to go ahead and start that. So the method I would
like to use in the designing of our components
will go like this, I'd like for us to design
our components based on the user task of this
app. Now the first task I'd like us to look at
is the authentication task. So for this task,
I'd like us to design all of the components
that will be needed to complete this task.
So let's come up here, let's have a text here,
I would zoom in to 200. And I would have a
text here, this is going to be the section where I
would have all of my authentication components. So
I would come here, I would select this textile to
have that there. So for the authentication task,
we have the login form and the signup form. So for
the login form, which components do we have there,
we have the input field, and we have the button.
So I would go ahead to design the input field.
So I would come here, I'll just say, inputs. Now
this is going to be my placeholder. So I would
come here and I'll use the body small text for
that. And I would keep it selected, then create
an auto layout on it. Now when I create an auto
layout, and it out, add the fill color, like this,
then I'll just stretch it to this point. Now
I'll still keep this auto layout selected,
come here and make sure that the content of the
auto layout is aligned to the left. And that's
fine. Now for the corner radius property, I would
give it a corner radius value of eight to have
that now outcome here and I would rename this to
impute field. Now while this is here, I'll select
the background color for the input field itself,
then the text here, I'll give it this off text
color here. And I'd like this input field to have
a stroke color, which is going to be the color of
the off text also. So I can have this. Now this
is sorted, we are done with creating a imputes
field. This impute field is what we are going to
reuse for the collection of emails, passwords,
phone numbers, so I'll go ahead keep it selected
and out, come here and click on Create components.
Now the next thing to create will be our button
components. So I would come here and I would have
this text here and for that text outcome here now
to select the button text for that Now I'll keep
the text selected and I'll create an auto layout
on the text. Now outcome here, for the Button Auto
Layout out, make sure the padding around items
value is set to 16. Now, same happened for this,
the padding around items value for this input
field is also 16. So take note of that. Now for
this button components outcome here now give it
this color, which is the surface color. Now for
the text, their outcome here, and I'll give it the
surface text color, which is white. Now outcome
here, I would select the button auto layout, come
here, now align the content of that auto layout
to stay at the center. Still keep it selected,
come here and give it a corner radius of eight.
And there we have our button components created.
So I would come here out, rename this to button,
then come here and click on Create components. And
there we have created our button components. Now
the next component I'd like for us to create here
under the authentication task will be the input
field, but the users will have to impute their
verification code in now that input field will
not look like this, it's going to look different.
So I'd like for us to go ahead and do that. So
I would come here, out of habit text here, let's
just say zero. And I'll keep the number selected,
then go ahead and create an auto layout on that
number. Now I'll keep the auto layout I just
created selected, come here and align the content
of the auto layout to stay at the center of the
auto layout, then I'd come here and add the fill
color to that auto layout. Now I'd come here, I
would select the pencil. And I'll just draw a line
horizontally, then I'd click on Done. And this
line I just created here will be grabbed and taken
into that auto layout that has that number zero.
And you can see that the line is placed here. Now
what I'll do is this outcome here, inside this
auto layout, now I would select this straight line
that I created, which is called vector one here,
when I select it, I would come here and now change
its horizontal resizing value from fixed width to
fill container. So that I can have that now I have
a problem here, the padding around value for this
auto layout is really big. So I would select the
auto layout outcome here and I would set it eight.
When I set it to eight, it's going to look
like this. Now I'd like it to be like this,
because if I am placing these components on my
screen, I would most likely increase the width.
And as you can see, when I increase the width,
the number zero just stays the way it is. But
the line itself stretches across the container,
which is actually what I want. So this is okay,
now, now seems the verification code will be a
four digit verification code, I like to have this
component go into four places. I'll go ahead and
do that. So I'll keep this component selected.
And I'll create another auto layout on top of
it like this. Now this auto layout that I just
created is called prim to out, keep it selected,
come here and now it sets its direction property
to horizontal direction. When I set that
to horizontal direction, I would come here
and I would set the padding around items value to
zero, just like that. Now outcome here now expand
the frame to auto layout. Now just so that I can
access the frame one Auto Layout inside of it. Now
when I select that frame one Auto Layout inside of
it, I'll duplicate it. And you can see that I have
duplicated this into four places. Now I'll come
back here how to select the frame to auto layout,
and how to set the spacing between items value
to zero, just to have this now let's check to
see if this auto layout itself is a responsive
auto layout. So I'll keep it selected still an
outcome here and I'll try to expand it. And as
you can see if I expanded horizontally, the layout
itself is not responding to that expansion. So
I would Ctrl Z to go back to how we were before.
And at this stage, what I'm going to do is this
out, select the individual sub Auto Layout inside
this main Auto Layout out select this one,
which is frame one outcome here now to set its
horizontal resizing value to pill container. And
I'll do that for all of them just like that. Now
when I select the frame to auto layout now and I
increase the size horizontally, you will see that
it's all responsive. And that's what I want. So
I would keep this here, I would rename these two,
verification imputes keep it selected, come here
and click on Create component and that's sorted.
So at this stage, I'd like for us to go ahead
and create our authentication screams. So let's
create a section for that. Not a page actually.
I'd say authentication screams authentication Hi
Fi screens just like this. So I would come here,
I'd have an iPhone that in Promax screen here,
and I would rename this, make sure you rename
your layout at this stage. So I would rename
this to splash. And we all know what the splash
screen is. Yeah, that's the screen you see,
when you launch an app for outcome here, I'll
change the color of the splash screen to this.
And on the splash screen, I'd like for us to have
the logo of the brand. And the logo of this brand
is really easy. It's just VXS t, just like that.
So I would keep the text selected outcome here,
now go with the headline to bold, and I'd work
with this. So I'll keep that text selected,
come here and align it horizontally and align it
vertically. And that's okay. So this is our splash
screen. So after the splash screen, the next
screen to create will be the screen where the user
will have to select the authentication action.
So I will duplicate the splash screen, I'll
take this out. And I'll change the color of this
screen now to this, then come here and rename it
of selection. You can call it whatever you want to
call it. Now over here, out, bring in the button
components out, go to my Assets panel out,
bring this in and out, align it to the center
horizontally, now expand it to this point. Now
for me to expand it properly, I would need to
apply my grid style on this layout. So I would
come here and now apply my mobile grid style here.
So that I can use this as my guide to properly
expand these buttons. So I'd like the button
to take up two column grids. And that's what
I have here. So I would come here, I'll change
the text to login. And I would bring in another
button components here. And I'll change these to
get started. Now outcome here, select this
button components and change its color to this
just to make a difference. So I would
keep this here. And I'll keep this here.
And that's fine. So I would select this,
and now align it to the center vertically.
And I'd bring this in place this Get Started
button right under this login button. But I'll
use the row grid to ascertain the space value
out give to that. So I have 1234 rows here,
and it's into four places is 32. So I have a 32
px bottom margin space between this login button
and the get started button. Now I think the row
grid is not really visible. So I would come here,
I'd go to my row grid saved style, I'd click
on Edit style out, select rows and out,
increase the opacity of that color to 20. So this
is sorted, this cream is sorted. Now if the user
goes ahead to click on the login button here, it
means the user will go to the login page, right.
So I'll create that now. So let's zoom in.
Let's take this out. And let's click on layers
and change the name of this frame to log in
page. And what I'll do is this when I zoom in,
I'll bring this here. So what I'll do is I'll just
have logo stay here, out, come here now to select
headline to bold, that's too big out GUI headline
three board, that's okay. So out align it to stay
at the center horizontally, and I'll bring it down
to this point, then I'll change the color to this.
Now what I'll do next is to have my login form
created. And I'll do that with my input field
here, which is this. Now I'd like this input field
to stretch from here to here, just like that.
Now, this input field would have a label here.
So I'll just give it a label here that says enter
email address. I'll keep label here. Now the space
between this liberal and this input field is 16 px
have two row spaces between this label text and
this input field. Now for the input field, I'll
change the placeholder text from inputs to enter
email address. That's okay. So I would come here,
I'd have another input field here, which is going
to be used for the password. So I'll change the
placeholder here to enter password. And I'll give
this input field its own label or duplicate this.
And first of all, I would say okay, the space
between this input field and this liberal text
should be 1234568 times six is 48. So I'd like a
48 px margin space between this input field and
this liberal text. So that's sorted. Now I'd like
a 16 px space between this liberal text and this
impeach field. So I would come here and I'll edit
this from enter email address and password. That's
okay. let's align this properly. So the next thing
I'd have here is the login button. So I'll bring
a button component here. And for this button
components, I'd like to have your margin space
here of that two px. So it's going to be 1234.
So I'll bring this here, place this there. And
let's zoom out, let's stretch this to this point
and stretch this to this point, then I'll change
the text of the button to login. Let's see how
it looks. Okay, this doesn't look really good,
the spacing is not really consistent. So I'll zoom
out. And I'd have the space between this label
text and this input field to be 32 px, actually,
so it's going to be 1234. So I'd have that stay
there. And I'd have this stay here. Then I'd have
123456, which is 48 px. So let's see. Hi, looks.
So this looks okay. Now, I like us to have a text
here, which is going to be the forgot password.
txt, forgot password. So let's keep this here. And
let's have that stay 16 px away from this input
field and 16 px away from this button component.
So I would select the text, and I would make sure
it is a body small text. And that's okay. So I'll
just zoom out, you can see that we have that. So I
would go ahead and create the signup page for our
authentication task. So I would come here, I'll
click on layers, and I would rename this to sign
up page. And if you come here, the only difference
we are going to have here is the fact that we are
going to have an additional input field to collect
the user's phone number. So this means that I'll
take this out for now, take this out for now.
And I'd have another placeholder here, which
is going to have a margin top space of 32 px,
which is 1234. I'll bring this here and out, bring
in an input field, which is going to stay here,
then out, stretch the input field to this point.
Now I'll use this second input field to collect
the user's phone number. And I'll change the
placeholder here to phone number, then I'll use
this thought imputes field to collect the user's
password, just like that. Now I'll go ahead and
I'll bring in a button here. And this button
is going to have a 48 px margin top space,
it's going to be 123456. I'll bring this here. And
I'll change the text here to sign up. So I'll zoom
out, I'll keep this selected out, stretch this to
this point and out, stretch these to this point.
And that sorted, so we have created a login screen
and our signup screen. Now when the users click
on the Sign Up button here, the users will be
taken to that page where they would have to enter
the verification code that was sent to their phone
number. So we are going to go ahead to create that
page. So I would come here and out rename this
verification page. And I'll take all of this
out over here. After the logo, I would have a
rectangle that's going to be that's going to
be this big. I like the rectangle to be 48 px
tall rectangle, just like this out, zoom out,
or have this here and out, stretch the
rectangle to this point. And I'd have the
rectangle have this background color. Now on
this rectangle, I would have a text that says
a verification code has been sent to just like
that. So I'll keep this text here. And I'll use
a body small text for that, then out align the
text to the center horizontally, then I'll keep
this text aligned to the horizontal center of the
page, just as the like this. And that's okay. And
that's okay. So I'll go ahead and bring in
that input components for the verification
code. But before I do that, let's change the
color of this text. So I would come here,
and I'll give you this color. Then I'll
click on the Assets panel now and I'll bring
in this component. Now for this component, I'll
keep it selected First things first, I'll change
the color of that components out, select the
individual items inside the components. And now
change these to the background color that we have.
Just like this. And that's okay. Now for the lines
that we have, I'll change the color of all those
lines to this. And for the numbers. I'll change
the color of the numbers to this. And that's
okay. So I would keep this selected. Now increase
the width to this point. So let's zoom in. So now
we can organize this properly. So I will keep this
here and how to snap the heights. This points just
like this. So I'd have a placeholder text there.
That's going to say enter very occasion code,
just like this. And now change the color of
that text to this. So let's go ahead, and let's
change the color of this label text that we have
here to this, change this to this, come here,
change this to this and change this to this. Now
for the Enter password text here, I'll change
this also. And for the Forgot Password text,
I'll change this. And that's okay. Now, let's
go back to our verification code page. And let's
have this button come up to this point. So it's
going to be 123456. Out keep this here, and I just
have a verified text, just like that. So at this
stage, we have created a verification page for our
authentication task. Now when the users click on
the Verify button, we are going to need a pop up
that would show up on the screen to let the users
know that their verification has been successful.
Now, how do we create that pop it simple outcome
here, I would select the frame to now creates a
pop up just like this. Now the reason I'm creating
this here is so that I can use the width of this
layout to set the width of this pop up. Now the
definite way to do this is this, if you come here,
and you select this page, you will see that the
width is 428. Now the margin space on this layout
is 16. Here, and 16 here, which is 32, right, so
to get the container space here, and use the width
of the container space for this, my pop would be
me subtracting 32 from 428. So I would just select
this outcome here, I would say four to eight minus
32. And that's going to be the width for my pop.
And this is it as easy as that. So I would come
here and I'll give it a corner radius of eight,
then I would go ahead and I'll give it this
background color, when I give it this background
color, then I'll have a text right inside that
layout that's going to say, pull number verified,
or whatever you want to say. So I would come here
and I would select a better textile. For that,
I would go with the body large textile just like
this out, align it to the center horizontally,
now out bring in the button components here and
out have a Proceed button here that the user will
click on to go to the homepage. And we are done
creating this. So I would select this, go to the
Layers tab and out, call this verify popup just
like that. So that pop up is going to show up when
the user enters their verification code here and
click on the Verify button. So I'll grab this now.
And I'll place it here. And that's fine. So at
this stage, I'd like to say that we are done with
creating all of the screens that we need for our
authentication task. So this is going to take us
to the next task of our app. And that task is
actually the fund task where users will have
to fund their wallets or their accounts so that
they can invest. So I would come here, and I'd
have this here. I'll change this to fund accounts.
So all of the components that are heavier will be
the components that will aid the user to fund
their accounts on this app. So let's go ahead
and let's do that. Now what you need to take
note of is this, for a user to fund the account,
the user will have to go to the homepage of the
app first, right? Because it is from the homepage,
that dude see the fund account button. So what
does this mean? This means that we need to create
components for the homepage and have our homepage
sorted first, before we handle different account
routes. So let's go ahead and let's do that. On
the homepage, the first component that we are
going to have will be a card components that will
display the balance that we have in our account.
And it is still on that card components that we
are going to have the one account button. So let's
go ahead and let's create that. So I would have
a text here is going to say primary accounts,
I would keep that text selected. And I would set
the typography style to body small boat. Now let's
zoom in to 200. So this is it. Now outcome here
and I'll create another text, which is going to
be like the account number or the account ID I
would say this and I'll keep that selected also.
Now I would set this to body small. So now I
would select both of these, and I'll create
an auto layout on the both of them. Now when
that auto layout is created out make sure that
the padding around items value is set to zero for
now. Now outcome here How to select this text and
how to set its horizontal resizing value to fill
container out, select this here, and how to set
its horizontal resizing value to fill container.
And for the height outcome here and out sets
the height property here to auto height to
make it balanced. Now we have this created
to outcome here, I'll add a fill color to this.
Now, I'll duplicate this, I'll bring this here.
And I'll change this text to account balance,
or let's just say available balance. Actually,
that's not the account balance, I would say
available balance, and here I'll write down the
available balance, that's fine. So I'll keep this
here also. Now, what I'll do is I would select
these two auto layouts, and now add an auto layout
on the both of them for this new auto layout that
I have created, I would come here and I would set
the spacing between items value to 24. And out
select this auto layout that inside this new auto
layout, and how to set its horizontal resizing
value to fill container. And I'll do that for this
also. Now I would select this new auto layout and
add a fill color of white to it to have this now
you can see that this is actually responsive.
And that's okay. Now, I'd like to bring in
a button component and place it inside this
auto layout so that that button will be used for
the font accounts action. So I would come here
and bring in a button component here, then
how to select that button component in the
in the design tree here, hold it and grab
it into this frame seven auto layout,
which is our auto layout. And you can see that
the button component is placed inside this auto
layout. Now I'd like this button component to
look different. So I would keep it selected.
Come here and I would set its top padding
value to eight and its bottom padding value
to eight. So I can have this now change this text
to font accounts, just like this. And that's okay.
Now I'll go to the feather icons plugin. And I
look for an icon that out place on the right side
to make the components just look better.
Let's come in here, let's just type in home.
I'll bring this in actually bring this here
and replace it here. Now I would select all of
these and I'll create an auto layout on all of
them. Now a new auto layout called frame eight
has been created. Now inside this frame eight
auto layout, we have this auto layout here
and this icon. So I would select this auto layout
now that's inside the frame. It's auto layout. And
now to set the value for its horizontal resizing
property to fill container. And I'll leave this
set to fixed we know how to select the frame. It's
Auto Layout now, which is a main Auto Layout now,
and I would come here and I would set the spacing
between items value to 24. When I do that, I would
come here and add a fill color to this. Now add
the fill color to the auto layout to have this.
And the final thing I'll do here is to come
here and set the padding around items value
to 16. When that's done, I'll give it a corner
radius of eight. To have this now I can expand
this to this point like this. And you can see that
this component is responsive. And that's that.
So let's go ahead and let's play around with
the colors of the elements on this component.
So I would select this text here, and I'll give
it this color, I would select this now give it
this color do same for this and do same for
this then for this out select the icon itself,
and that's fine. So I would rename this to balance
card, or whatever you want to call it. I will keep
it selected and now click on Create components.
And here we have our components created.
So on the home page Still, I'd like to display a
list of recent transactions that's been carried
out on the app. So let's go ahead and let's
create a component that's going to serve that
purpose. So I'd come here out create a text out
call that deposit come here now to select the
body large bold text then I'd come here now create
another text and I'd have this which is going to
be a dates that deposit happened. So how to select
these two text and how to create an auto layout on
the both of them. Now how to select this text
inside the auto layout and how to set its
horizontal resizing value to fuel container.
Now do that for this also. Now out select
the auto layout and how to set it spacing between
items value to four. And that's okay. Now for this
deposit text. I'll change the color to this. And
for the date here. I'll change its color To this,
and that's okay. So I'll keep this here. And
the next thing I'll do is to have a frame here,
that's going to be 48 by 48. I'll keep it
selected and out, give it a corner radius of 100.
To make it round, then I'll go to the feather
icons plug in and out have an icon there,
that signifies incoming, which is
this, I would select this icon now,
and I'll place it on top of this 48 by 48 px
frame that I created. When I placed it there,
I would come here now to set its constraints
value two center for the horizontal axis and
center for the vertical axis. And that's okay.
Now select this frame, which is now a circle
and out set its color, let's set it to green like
this. And for the icon, outset, it's colored this
and that's okay. Now for this frame, now that
I have created, I'll bring you to our PC here,
and how to select all of this and out create an
auto layout on the both of them. Now for this
new auto layout, I would come here and I would set
it spacing between items value to 16. And I would
come here now to set its alignments value to the
center just like this. Now out keep it selected to
come here and add a fill color to it just like
this. Now I would come here now and I would create
this text. And this text is going to be a
body large bold text, I would come here and
create another text, which is going to just like
display the balance out keep that selected and
out make it a caption text, just like this. Now to
select both of them, create an auto layout on the
both of them and sets the spacing between items
value to for now to select the text inside the
auto layout now and how to set its horizontal
resizing value to feel container to have that
and that's sorted. So I'll select this now
and I'll give it a fill color of white.
Now for the color of the text out set this to
something lights like this. And this will be
something like that. Now what I'll do is I'll
select all of these and I'll create an auto layout
on all of them. First things first out align the
content of the auto layout to stay at the center,
then I'll add a fill color to the auto layout to
have this now for the spacing between items value
of this new auto layout. Now, I like to set it to
76. And that's okay. Now for the padding around
items value, I'd like to set this to eight. And
that's okay. Now let's check to see if this auto
layout is responsive. As you can see, it's not. So
let's sort that out. And to sort it out is really
easy. I would select this frame here, this auto
layout here, I would select this auto layout here.
And I'll set its horizontal resizing value to fill
container. Now when I set this to fill container
out, select the auto layout that's inside it,
which is frame eight and out set its horizontal
resizing value to fill container also, now I'll
make sure all of these sets of field container so
I'll select the items to be sure that they are
also set to feel container. Now when I select
the frame 12 Now, which is our major frame,
you would see that this is now responsive.
And that's okay, so I'll keep it selected, come
here and now set the corner radius value to eight.
And I have this I'd like to duplicate this to have
a withdrawal component where the circle is going
to be red and the icon is going to be different.
So I would set the position of this icon to let's
set it to 180. That's the angle position. That's
what I'm setting here. Or you can call it the
rotation property of that icon. So I'm setting it
to 180 degrees. And I'll change this with roll.
Then you can change all of these details. If you
want to change them out, select the circle itself,
which is this frame, and I'll change the color
to this and that's okay. So outcome here out,
select this out, rename this to withdraw our
card, keep it selected, make it a component,
okay, that's supposed to be deposit card.
So out select this column here and out,
rename this to deposits card. Keep it selected.
Come here and click on Create components.
Then select this. Rename this to weave Travel
Card, keep it selected and make it a component
and that's sorted. Still on the homepage. We
are going to have a banner that will be used
to copy referral links. So I would go ahead and
out creates that. So I'd have this text here.
that's going to see invites your friends out,
keep that selected. And I would go with this
textile here, which is the body large bold
textile. And I'd have another text here,
that's going to be invite your friends with this
pack code. And I'll go with the caption textile
here. And that's cool. So I would select this,
when I select it, I would create an auto layout,
and outcome out sets the spacing between items
value to eight, then out, select the text items
inside this auto layout and how to set these
to fill container. And I'll do that for this
also. Now the next thing I'd like to do is to
have a frame layout here, that's going to be
48 by 48. And I'll keep it selected still out,
give it a corner, reduce value of 100, then come
here and give it that color. Now I would go over
to the feather icons plugin and Outlook one and I
would look for an icon I can use on that. So I
like to use this icon here, I would select it,
or bring it here and place it on this frame
layout. Now when I placed there, I would make sure
it's at the center, then I'd come here now to set
its horizontal constraints value to center and its
vertical constraints value to center. And that's
okay, now select that icon, then I'll set its
color to this. And that's okay now to select all
of this creates an auto layout on it. So I would
come here and I would align the contents of that
auto layout to always stay at the center. Now I'll
keep this auto layout selected, and I'll give it
a fill color which is going to be the background
color like this. Now, I would select this auto
layout that is inside this main auto layout. Now
as you can see, it's the brim 12 auto layout that
has this text, when I select it out, come here,
and I'll set this to fill container. And when I
select the main auto layout, now you'd see that
this is a responsive auto layout, which means
we are good to go. Now for the spacing between
items value of this auto layout, I like to set
it to 24. And for the padding around items value,
I'd like to set it to 16. To have that, then come
here and set the corner reduce value to eight.
And here we have a component. So I would keep this
selected. Now rename this to refer our banner,
then come here and click on Create component
to make it a component. And that's okay. Now on
our homepage, we have one final component, which
is going to be a very interesting components to
create. And that's going to be the navigation
components on our homepage, which is going to
be at the bottom. So let's see how we can create
that components before we put our homepage screen
together. So I would come here and I would get
the home icon from the feather icons plugin.
I'll type in home there, I'll bring this in. Now
I'd like to zoom in at this point so that you
can see clearly, when I placed this icon here,
I would come here and I would create a text.
And I'll call that home. Now for this home text, I
would create an auto layout on it. And I would set
the padding around items value for that auto
layout zero, then set its alignment position
to the center. Now select the Home text that
is inside this auto layout. And now to set its
horizontal resizing value to fill container.
Now out keep this text auto layout here,
then I would select the Home icon and that text
auto layout. And I will create an auto layout on
the both of them. Now this auto layout is frame
15. What I'll do now is I would come here and
I would set the spacing between items value
for this auto layout to for when I do that,
I would come here now to set the alignments of
the contents in that auto layout to always be at
the center. Now outcome here and how to select the
Home auto layout and how to set its horizontally
resizing value to fill container. And that's okay,
just stretch this and it's going to be sorted.
Now at this stage. What I'll do is this out
have a frame layout here. That's going to be 48
by 48. And I'll grab this pre empting
Auto Layout now and I'll place it on
this 48 by 48 px frame layout, make sure it's
at the center. When I place it at the center,
I would select the frame 16 frame layouts, which
is our 48 by 40. It's layouts now and I would make
it an auto layout. Now when I make it an auto
layout, I'll bring it here and I'll rename this
to Home link. Now after I rename it to
HomeLink outcome here and now set its alignment
to the center so that the content of that auto
layout will always be at the center. Now the
padding top value is set to three out, set it
to four, just so that we are going to have even
numbers all around, I would set this to four also,
and this outset four, and this outsets. Four,
just to have this. So at this stage, what I'd
like to do now is to have other navigation links.
So I'll keep this home link Auto Layout selected,
and I'll create another auto layout on top of it.
Now this auto layout that I just created has
a padding around items value of 16. Yeah,
I'll leave it set to 16. Because actually, that's
what it's supposed to be now outcome here out,
expand this new auto layout, and how to select
the Home link or to layout and I'll duplicate it
like this into three places. And that's
because I want to have just three items
there. Now outcome here, I'll change this from
home to invest. And I'll change this from home
to transact. Let's select our frame 16. And let's
add the fill color to it to have this. So if I
expand the frame 16, you'd see that the icon and
the text is just that it's not responsive. So I'd
like to change that. So to change that out, select
this home link sets these to fill container,
select this, do that also select this and do that
also. Now when I select frame 16, and I increase
the width horizontally, you would see that this
text wrap into the next line is actually fixed.
So for this icons, let's go ahead and let's change
this icon to a better icon and these two are
better icon. So I would come here, I would go to
the feather icons plugin. And I would like to have
this icon. So I'll bring this here. And I would
come in here and I will trace the auto layout that
has that you can see it's still called Home link,
I'll change that to invest link, when I change it
to invest link, you'd see that to have the home
icon inside here. So I would come here now,
I would select this bar chart icon now. And I'll
take it inside the InVEST link auto layout. Now
place it right inside here. And you can see that
it is here at the bottom. So I would select the
Home icon and out, delete it with the delete key
on my keyboard, then come here, grab this invest
icon, hold it and take it upwards like this. So
I'll go ahead and I'll do same for the transact
link here. So I'll keep this selected. Come
here out, rename this to bottom navigation,
keep it selected and click on Create components
and that components has been created. So at this
stage, we can go ahead to make use of all of these
components in designing our homepage. So to design
our homepage, out, come here out, select the frame
to and I'll bring in an iPhone fatin Promax frame
here. Now zooming to this point, now I would
select this iPhone 13 Pro Max frame, rename this
to home. When I do that, I would come here and how
to apply the grid style on it. And when I do that,
let's zoom in to 200. out go ahead and I would
bring in the menu icon using the feather icons
plugin. So I'll use that one there. Now whenever
you bring in an icon and you want to place it
into a layout, make sure the icon is inside that
layout here in the design tree. As you can see,
currently, this icon which is aligned justified
is not placed inside this layout, which is our
homepage. So what I'll do is I would come here
in the design tree, click on it to select it,
hold it and drag it into the home layout. And as
you can see it is now inside the home layout. So
I would come here, and I'll place this here. So I
would count it row spaces from the top 1234567 and
eight. And that's okay. So I'll have a text here.
So I can come here and I can say hi and for laka.
Now I'd like to call your attention to something
important. And that is the fact that as you can
see here, I have the name of the user written
here, which is N for lucky. Now the question you
should ask is this, how did I arrive at displaying
the name of the user here when in the signup form,
I did not collect the name of the user. If you
remember, in my signup form, I only collected the
email address the phone number and the password
of the user, which means that the app itself does
not have a record of the name of the user. So the
question you'd ask, which is no malice. How did I
arrive at displaying the name of the user
here? Now this is going to be your first
assignment in this course, because I'd like you
to come here in the authentication section here
and refactor the authentication flow here. To
collect the name of any user that's signing up
to this app. Now I'll leave this open without
giving you a guide on how to do that. I'd like to
see your thoughts process on how to refactor this
authentication process with the best experience.
And also with the fact that you would collect the
name of any user signing up to this application.
If you think coming here and adding another field
for the name collection is fine, go ahead and do
that. If you have another idea that can make the
experience better, go ahead and implement that.
Now when you implement the name collection in
the authentication task here, go ahead tagged me
on social media for my comments. That's your first
assignment in this course, then I can have another
text here. I'll bring this here. Now the next
thing I'd like to have here is the balance card.
So I would come here in the Assets panel, and
I'll bring this component in like this. Now,
I'd like to have four row spaces between this text
and the balance card. But before I do that, I like
to keep this balance card selected, then come here
and apply my shadow style that I saved. So it so
I would go with image shadow like this. Now let's
zoom into this point. And let's make sure we have
four row spaces. And that's okay, let's zoom out.
Now what we are going to do is to stretch this
to this point. And that's going to be successful
because our components is a responsive component.
So nothing is going to break. And this is okay.
So I would come here at the bottom here, out,
snap this to this roll line. And that's sorted.
So the next thing I'm going to have here is a text
that's going to say recent transactions out, keep
that selected and out go with a body large bold
text. So I'll make sure I have 1234 Group spaces
there. And that's sorted. So I'd have that there.
And I would select a different color for that.
I'll go with this. Now for this also out have
this color set this now just in case I forget to
set the color of the text as I proceed, you go
ahead and do that. So I would select this icon
also now change the color to this, that's okay.
Now right on that this will be sent transactions
text out have those transaction cards there.
So I'll bring this in, which is the opposite cut
out, give me the shadow style outcome here. I'll
give it a meet shadow style there. Let's zoom out
to this point. And I'll just stretch this to this
end here. And I'll make sure this snaps properly
too. And that's not going to be a problem because
a component is responsive. So let's look at the
space in between this card and this text out
zooming, you can see we have 123 I'll make this
four. Let's zoom out. Okay, that's actually too
far away. So I'll bring this here, I'll have two
row spaces. Okay. So I would have this one here.
So I'd have two spaces from this text
to this card. And if I select the text,
you'd see that I have one row space and two space
before this card. And that's okay. So what I'll do
now is I would go ahead, I'll duplicate this. And
when I duplicated, I'd make sure I have just one
row space, which is SPX, I'll bring in this other
one, which is four, which is for a withdrawal
event. Outcome. Yeah, I'll give it a meet shadow
out, zoom out and out, snap this to this points.
And I'll make sure it's just eight px space.
So I'll bring this here and that's okay.
Now I'll have just three recent transactions here.
So I'll go ahead and bring in this referral banner
and upload it here. So I'll make this snap to
the end also, just the other point, now zooming,
and I'll make sure I have a consistent space in
here. So I'll have a 48 px margin space over here,
which is going to be six row spaces, right. So
I'd have 123456. So I'll bring this in place here.
So I'll zoom out, and at this point, what I'll
bring in will be a bottom navigation components.
I bring it up let's see here. Let's zoom in
and let's make sure this is properly placed.
As you can see I have properly placed this so I
would keep it selected. Come here and I'll change
the fill color to this out select this, change
the fill color to do this, select this select
this I'll change the fill color to this now select
the icon itself now change the fill color to this
or do that for this also. And I'll do that for
this also. Now for the text out select the text
and I'll change the fill color to this and that's
okay. Now for the text color of this navigation
link. I like the text color actually to be pure
white so that it can be really present there.
And I think this is better. And that's it. So
we have just designed our homepage now using the
components that we created. So I would also advise
that while designing, it's also good most times to
test what you're designing, so I would select
this column here, and I would click on present
to see how this is going to look like
actually. So this doesn't look good like this,
I like to present this inside an iPhone
device. So outcome here, click on prototype,
click on prototype Settings and select a
device here, which is iPhone 13 products.
When I do that outcome, help select this layout
once more, and I'll click on present again,
that's going to sort it. And this is what we have,
this looks good, you can come here and present
this in full screen just like this, to see it
better. So let's go ahead and let's keep designing
our application. So I'll press the Escape key on
my keyboard to go out of that full screen display
and not come back here. So the next action I'd
like to design for will be the action of the
user clicking on different accounts button. So
when the user clicks on the fund accounts button,
I'd like to display a pop up that will allow the
user choose the method in which they would like
to fund the account with and that's easy,
because we have actually created a pop up
before. So I would come here, I'll duplicate
this pop pop, and I'd have the Pop Pop stay here.
And right inside this pop up here, I would
have one button here, which is going to say
bank transfer. And I'd have another button here
that's going to present the option to fund the
account with a debit card. So I'd have this
the here and now expand this to this point.
Now expand this to this point. I'd also keep this
here and expand this to this point. Now to expand
this to this point, I'll keep it selected and
how to center it horizontally. So outcome here,
I'll bring this downwards. And I'd have it
textured that's going to say select method.
So I'll change the color of that text to this. And
that's going to be cool. So I would select this
pop now, and I would rename it from verify pop
to bond method pop up, keep it selected, and I
would make it a component. And that's going to be
it. So when the users click on bond account here,
they would have this pop pop show up asking them
to choose the method in which they would like to
fund their account with now let's say the select
the bank transfer method, they will be taken to
the page where they would have that happen. So for
that out creates that page now. So I would come
here, I'll duplicate this, and I would rename it
bank transfer, when I rename it to bank transfer,
I would come here and I would take all
of these outs. And I would also take
the bottom navigation out also. So what I'd have
here is an icon that will direct the users back
to the previous page. So I would go to further
icons. When I come here, I would scroll down,
and I would select this icon for that. So I'll
take this out. And I'll bring this here. And
as you can see, this icon is not inside this
layout. That's why this smart guy is not active.
So I would come here, I would select this
icon and I'll take it into these layouts,
just like this. Now when I select it, and I move
it around, you'd see that the smart guide is
active. So I'll make sure that I have it spaces
from the top 12345678. And that's correct. So
I will keep that icon select and I'll change the
color of the icon vector to this. And that's okay.
The next thing I'd have here is a title for this
page. That's going to say bank transfer, you can
call it whatever you want to call it. So I'll use
the headline three bold text for that. I'll keep
that there how to center this horizontally
actually, to be sure it's at the center
horizontally. And that's fine. Now I'd come here,
and I'd have bits here. So I would have these
details here. So what I'll do is I'd make sure I
have 1234. Okay, I'd have it's row spaces there,
I'd have 12345678. So what we are going to have
here is the destination account details where the
user should make the bank transfer to so here's
the account number. Here's the account name and
here is the bank name. And that's it. So I would
come here and I'd have a button component here,
out align it to the center and I would stretch it
to this point and stretch it to this point also,
I would have 123 456. So I have seven, and eight.
So I'd have a two row spaces there. Now what I'd
have on this button will be copy account number.
So the user can just click on this button to copy
the account number here. So I have sorted the
routes for funding the account on this app with
bank transfer. So let's go ahead and let's create
the page where the user will use to fund the
account with their debit card. So outcome here,
so I will change this debit debit card, or align
this to the center, that's okay, I'll take this
out, then I'd come here, I'll take this out also,
then I'd have all of this here. So I would have
it row spaces from this icon also. So let's zoom
in so that we can count better. So I would have
12345678. I'll keep this here. And I'd have one
two, I'll have that there. out, zoom out. So
this is going to be the page that will enable
the user fund their accounts on this app
with a debit card. So what we have here is,
the user will enter the amount and have
the option to select that they want to use
the existing card that they have on this app, or
they would like to add another card. So let's fix
some alignment issues here. Let's keep this there,
come here and keep this here also, then come here,
balance that's there. And keep that there. Also,
I would also come here and make sure that this
is sorted also here. So for the action of adding
another card, we are going to see how to do that
as we proceed for now let's go ahead and let's
have a button component here, align that to the
center horizontally, keep that there, keep that
there, then for the text out, say font accounts.
And that's that. So if the users click on the
font accounts button, they would have this pop
up show up for them to choose the method they want
to use, when they select the bank transfer method,
they would have this page show up,
if they select the debit card method,
they would have this page show up also, they
would have this page show up. Now, if the user
clicks on this fund accounts button, when they
want to fund the account with a debit card,
the user will be taken to another page, which
is going to indicate that the account has been
successfully funded. So I'll duplicate this to
have that there. Now, before we work on that page,
I'd like to change the name of this page from bank
transfer to debit card transfer. Now for this page
here, out, rename it to transfer successful.
Come here, I'll take all of these outs.
I'll take this out also. And I'd have a frame
here, which is going to be 100 by 100 frame,
that's how it's going to look like that's
quite small. So I'll make this 240 by 240. And
I'll just work with this. So I'll give it this
color. And I'll give it a corner radius of 200
to make it a circle. And I'll go over to the
feather icons plugin. And over here in the
feather icons plug in out bring in this icon, and
that icon will be placed on top of this frame.
Now go ahead and use the Scale tool to scale that
icon to this point, just like this. Now, when you
scale the icon, make sure that the constraints
of that icon is set to the center horizontally
and the center vertically. So I would come here
now I would select this icon and I'll change
the color of that icon to this when our habit text
here that would say count funded successfully,
or you can have whichever text you want to have
they that's fine. So I would come here and I'll
change the color of this to that. So after
that, I would have a button component here,
that will redirect the user to the InVEST page. So
I would say invest. Now when they get this page,
they would have the option to click on the InVEST
button here to go straight to the InVEST page
where they can invest. So that's the next page
we are going to look at we are going to look at
creating the InVEST page where users can invest
in stocks. So to create that page, it means that
we need to create the components that the page
will need. So let's go ahead and let's see how
to create the components for that page. So for
the InVEST page, the first component I would have
there will be a little card component that will
be used to display the cash amount that the user
has. So I would come here and I would create that.
This is the fund accounts component section here.
So I would have the invest component section here.
And to create that card, I would have this here,
I would say cash. And I'll use the body small
textile for that. And I'd have an amount here,
just any amounts. Okay, so I would use body large
bold here, then I'll just select the both of them,
I would create an auto layout on the both of
them, make sure the padding around items value
is set to zero, then I'll come here and I'll add
the fill color to it. To have that now select
the cache text and set the horizontal resizing
value to fill container and do that for this or
that text on the here, which is the amount of
cash that the user has. Now when that's sorted,
select the auto layout, and then come here and
set the space in between items value to for now,
I'll go over to the feather icons plug in, and
I'd look for an icon that I can use to represent
cash there. So I would scroll down and I'll look
for one of the icons here. So I am going to make
use of this icon here, I would select it, I'll
bring it here, then I would select both of these
and out create an auto layout on the both of
them the outcome here. And I would make sure
that the alignment value for this auto layout
is set to be top left corner of the auto layout.
So I would keep this auto layout selected, I
would add a fill color to it. And I would set
the spacing between items value to eight, then
set the padding around items value to eight,
then come here and I'd have the corner radius
value set it also. So over here, I would select
this auto layout inside the main Auto Layout now.
And I would set its horizontal resizing value
to feel container. And when I do that, you will
see that this component will be irresponsive
components just the way I want it to be. Now
let's go ahead and let's set the colors for this.
So I will set the color of this to that now set
this to this now for this icon out set the color
of this icon to this. So I'll keep this here, I'll
duplicate it, when I duplicate it out, go ahead,
change these two assets, then I'll leave the value
here just like this, or you can change it if you
want to change it. Now the next thing I'd like
to do is to take out that icon and have another
icon there. So I would go to further icons.
And I would have this selected for that. So
I'll bring this here, let's go to the Layers tab
here. And I would select the briefcase icon here,
which is this, I would select it here. And
I'll take it into the frame 19 Auto Layout,
just like this. And you can see that it is
staying here on the right side of the auto layout,
I would grab it and I'll take it to the left
side. Now I'll select this one, and I'll delete
it. And I have that. So I would select this icon
now and I'll change the color of this icon. And
this is sorted. So I would rename this to cash
card, whatever you want to call it is okay.
And I would rename this to assets card. And that's
okay. So I would select this, make it a component,
select this, make it a component. So let's go
ahead and let's create the other components
that we are going to need on the InVEST page. So
the next component, our need on the InVEST page
will be an input field component that the user
can use to search for top stocks that they would
like to invest in. So we have an input field here
already created, it's already a component. So what
I'm going to do is out duplicate it, I'll bring it
down here. And I'll keep this here. Now when you
duplicate the components like this, the duplicates
will be a child components. Now, I wouldn't love
to work with this as a child components. So what
I'm going to do is out out keep the components
selected, right click on it and out select detach
instance. Now when I select detach instance,
you would see that this is back to a regular auto
layout. So I would come here, and I would change
the name to such impute field, then what I'm going
to do is I would go to further icons now bring in
a search icon, which is this out, grab it and drop
it inside this auto layout, which is the search
input field auto layout. Now the issue is this.
I want this search icon to be smaller than this,
because it's quite too big. And as you can see it
has increased the height of the impute field. So
I'll keep the icon selected. Come here, and I'll
set this to 12. And I'll set this to 12. And that
I have that now I think 12 is too small outside
this to 16. And out set this to 16. And that's
sorted. So the next thing is this, I'd like
this icon to stay on the right side of this
impute field. So how do we do that? Just select
the search input field auto layout. Come here.
Click on the alignment and padding property. then
change this property from packed to space between,
and that's going to be sorted. Now let's change
the color of that icon. I'll change it from black
to this. Now I can select it now and make it a
component. And as you can see, it can be used
just the way you'd like it to be used. So let's
go ahead and let's create the next component that
we are going to have on our invest page. So the
next components will be the components that will
display the list of stocks that are available
to invest in, in this app. So let's come here,
let's have some space here, I'll use the brand
fetch plugin. To pull up the logo of a brand,
I'd have this Come here, I'll type in dangoty, or
press the Enter key on my keyboard. And I'd have
this here. So I would select this out, click on it
to select it, and I'd have it there in my canvas.
So I'll bring this here, and I'll make it a 24 by
24 frame logo just like this. Now when I make it
24 by 24. The next thing I'd love to have is the
price of this stock, I would have that out select
the caption text for that, then I would have
this, then I would have this, make sure I use
the caption text for that also, then I'll create
an auto layout on this and I'll set the padding
around items value to zero. Now out select
the text inside this auto layout and set its
horizontal resizing value to fuel container. Now,
I'd like to have an icon here that will indicate
decline or increase. So I would go to the feather
icons plugin. And I would bring this icon in,
and I place it here. Now I'll make this icon a
16 by 16 icon just like this, when I plus here,
how to select both of them. Now create an auto
layout on the both of them. Now for the spacing
between the auto layout, it's going to be set to
four. Now to select this auto layout that's inside
this framlington Auto Layout, I am talking
about the auto layout that has this number here,
I would select it, when I select it, outset its
horizontal resizing value to fill container,
then out select the frame 19 Auto Layout now, and
now add a fill color to it. Now let's go ahead
and let's select this icon. And let's make the
color to be green just indicates progress. Yeah,
so I would come here now, I would select both
of these and create an auto layout on the both
of them. Now for this auto layout here, I would
set the spacing between items value to eight,
it's already set it for me. So I'll just leave
it set to eight. Then I'll come here and I'll add
if fill color. To have this outcome here. Out
select this text now, which is inside this new
auto layout and outset it's horizontal resizing
value to fill container. And for this outset,
it's horizontal resizing values fill container.
Now when I select this frame 20 Auto Layout,
as you can see here, it's a frame 20 Auto Layout,
when I select it, and I resize it, you would see
that it's a responsive auto layout, just like
this. And that's what I want, actually. So I'll
bring this here. Now I'll go ahead to create a
text that will signify the title of that stock,
I'll just call it dang. Now I'd come out set this
to body large bold, and I'd have this day here
with this text. Now what I'll do is I would select
this and this text, and I'll create an auto layout
on both of them. Now outcome here now add
the fill color to this auto layout first,
then come here and align the contents of that auto
layout to the center. After that, I would set the
spacing between items value of that auto layout
to eight to have this now bring this here and I'd
have this here. The next thing to do is to have
all of these selected, then out add an auto layout
on all of them. Now for this new auto layout. Now,
I would set the spacing between items value to
eight, then come here, select this auto layout
and set its horizontal resizing value to fill
container, then how to select the auto layout now
and now add a fill color to it to have this now
for the padding around items value, I would set it
to eight and set the corner radius value to eight,
just like this. Now if I expand this, you'd
see that I have this component looking just
like this. And this is okay. So I want to select
it out, name this stock list and out make it a
component. That's fine. Now the next component I'd
like to have there on the InVEST page will be a
component that will be used to display the list of
stocks that the user have invested literally the
stock portfolio of the user. So I would come here
let's zoom in one small out have a 48 by 48 px
frim going out, give it a corner radius of 100 to
make it around, then I'll give it this color. Now
out, go to the brand fetch plugins, and out, look
for the paystack logo, which is this. Now outcome
here, I would right click on this paystack logo, I
like to pick out the background color. So I'll use
the Remove BG plugin. for that. I'll keep the logo
selected, and I'll make it a 24 by 24 px logo,
just like this, and I'll place it right at
the center of this circular frame that we have
created. Now when you place that on top of that
circular frame, make sure to set the constraints
value for the horizontal axis to the center
and for the vertical axis to the center. So the
next thing to do is to go ahead and I'd say pay
stack, I'll keep it selected, come here. And I'll
use the body large bold text for that. And right
under this, paste that text out have plus 345,
just to represent the appreciation value of that
stock. So I'll keep it selected and outcome here.
And I'll go with the body small text. Now I'd
make this to have a green color, just like this
and for the paste that text and make it to have
this color. So I would select both of these,
first of all, create an auto layout, make this
space in between items value to be set to four,
then out select this text, set it to fill
container. And for this outset to fill container
also now out expand this, and that's fine. Now
the next thing to do is to select all of this,
create an auto layout on all of them. When I
create an auto layout on this outcome, how to set
the spacing between items value to eight, and
out add the fill color to that to have this
now when I set this to eight outcome here
and out set the pattern around items value
to eight. Now I'd like for us to check to see
if this is a responsive auto layout. And as
you can see, it's not and that's because
I have not set the horizontal resizing
value for this auto layout inside of it to feel
container. So when I set this to fill container,
and I come here now you'll see that we have
a responsive layout. So I'll keep it selected
outcome here. Now it sets the corner radius value
to eight. And then we have our portfolio listing
component. So I would say portfolio portfolio
list. And I'll click on Create components.
So I think we have created all of the components
that we are going to need on our invest page. So
at this stage, I'd like for us to go ahead and
create our invest page. So I would come here now
out, select this out, duplicate it out,
rename this to invest. And I'd come here
and take all of this out. And now leave the
bottom navigation components, this time around
outcome here, what I'd have first will be that
cash card. So I'd have 1234 space before that.
But to see cash card, I'll bring the cash card in
here. And for this cash card, I'll change the fill
color of this cash card to this out, select this
and I'll change this also to this, I'll change the
text color here to this. And for this, I'll change
this to that. So I'll go ahead now. And I'll bring
in the Assets card. And I'll do the same to that
also come here, I'll change the color of that to
this. And this will be changed to this, change
this to this and this to this. And that's okay.
So what I'll do now is out arrange all of this
to stay organized. So I'd like this to take up
two columns. And I'd like this to come here and
take up two columns. So let's zoom in to be sure
that this is properly organized. So this is not
properly organized. And that's because I want
four row spaces before this. So I will bring
this down here. When I select this, I'd have 1234
And this is okay. So I'll bring this here. And
I'll bring this down here. So this is sorted, we
have this section sorted. So the next section of
this page will be the section where I would write
a text that's going to say top stocks to invest
in. So I would have eight row spaces before this.
So I would say 12345678. I don't have this to
hear. Now for the text here. I'd like this text
to be a body large text, not a body large bold
text. Now after this text, I'd like to have
that search field. So I would snap this to
this point. And I would go ahead to bring
in that search impute field which is this and
I'll just have only an eight px space between
this text here and the input field. So out
come here stretch these to this point. And
I'll change the placeholder fetch. So let's
change this from stock to stocks. And that's
fine. So the next component I'd like to have is
the stock list components. So I'll keep this here,
and actually give it a shadow effect so that we
can see that clearly. So let's zoom in. So I would
give it two spaces, one, two, and that's fine. So
out, snap this perfectly. And I would like this
stop here. And I would like this also, to stop
here. Let's zoom out. So I would duplicate this
and have this house. And let's duplicate this
here. Let's duplicate this hair also. So let's
zoom in to confirm that all our components are
aligned perfectly. So you can see this is okay,
this is okay. This is okay. And this is
okay. So that looks okay, now on have a
stock portfolio section. Now, to differentiate the
two sections out, bring in the button components,
and I would use it for something different this
time around. So I would have 1-234-567-8910 1112
spaces. So I'd have 12 Row spaces here, I would
zoom out, out stretch this to the end like this,
I would come here and align the content of this
button now to the left, then I would set its top
padding value to eight and the bottom padding
value to eight. Now what I have here will be
stock portfolio. Now to make this look different,
I'll keep this selected, come here now to set
the corner reduce value to zero, just like
this. Now what are we going to have here,
we are going to have the paste back component
here. So let's zoom in. And let's make sure
this is properly organized. So I'd have
1234 space before this. And that's okay,
outcome here. Now give it a shadow effect, just
like this now out, keep this selected, come here,
now change the color. So I would come here, I'll
change the color to this. So the green color
here needs to actually be thicker than it is now,
just like this. So I would make this to have two
columns, then I'll duplicate it and have this they
have also taken up two columns also. Now you can
go ahead and have other stocks listed here. That
if you want to have that, and here we are, we are
done with our invest page. Now since we won't be
able to display all of the stock portfolio here,
I would like to have a see all text here.
So this see all text will be brought in text
out copy here. And I'll duplicate this see all
text. And I keep you here also, and I'll change
the color of this, see all text or change this
and that's fine. Now the next flow will be this.
Now let's assume a user likes this talk here and
the user wants to invest in this talk means the
user will click on the stock and the user will
be taken to the stock Details page. Right. So
let's make that happen. I'd come here, select this
page, and I'll duplicate it, come here and change
this to stock details. And that's fine. So for
the stock Details page, I'll take all of this out
and out zoom in, then go to the feather
icons plugin to get that icon that signifies
going back to the previous page. And this is it.
I'll get it. I'll bring it here. And I'll make
sure that this icon is actually inside the stock
Details page. And I'll take this to this point.
And that's sorted out, select the icon
vector and I'll change its color to this.
So what do we have here, I like for us to have
a title here that's going to say stock details.
And this text should have a headline three bold
textile for it. So I would align it to the center
horizontally. And that's okay, now let's change
the color this and that's fine. So what I'd have
here will be a component that I would create, I
would just come here, I would have this frame to
select it and out create a frame
with it like this out set this eight,
then out sets the colored this van out sets the
color to this than out go to brand fetch to get
that logo and out place the logo right on that
frame layouts that I just created. I'll grab it
and upload it here. Now I'd keep it selected and
outset the horizontal constraints to center and
the vertical constraints to send that and that's
okay, so what I'll do now is out keep this frame
selected, rename this to stock detail. And then
I'll come here and I'd make it a component.
So I'll go to that page now. And over here I'd
have that stock detailed banner components placed.
This is it here. I'd have it stay
here out stretch it to this point.
and are stretched this this point,
that's okay. So I would come here now,
let's snap that in. And let's also make sure that
this is snapped in perfectly, just like this.
So over here I have 123. Let's make it four.
So over there have four row spaces between this
stock details, text, and this stock detail banner
components. And that's fine. So let's zoom out.
The next thing I'd have here will be the stock
price. And the appreciation value, I'll make sure
I have 1234 spaces. That's okay. Now I'll go ahead
to create a component that outplays here and and
that component will go into more details about
the stock. So let's go ahead and let's create that
component. So to create that component outcome
here, and now to select the frame to now create a
frame that's 42 px tall, just like this. Let's
zoom in to this point. When I create this frame
here, I'll come over here and I'll create a text
on this frame, I'd say my position, I'll keep this
text here, just like that. And that's fine. Now
for this text, I'll use the body small textile
that I have here, which is this. And that's okay.
Now I'll go ahead, I'll create another text here,
I'll actually make this text box to be this
Why'd not come here, now just type in 35. Now,
I'll keep this text box selected now and align
the content of that text box to stay at the right
select this frame layout now, and then make it an
auto layout. Now I would come here and I'll click
on the alignment and padding value, and out sets
the left padding to 16 and sets the right padding
to 16. Then out set the top padding to 12 and the
bottom padding to 12. Now I'd like this text to
always stay here and this text to always stay
here. So I would come here and now change this
from pact to space between. And that's okay. So if
I come here now, you'd see that if I take this in,
this is always staying here. And this is always
staying here. Same thing happens if I resize
the left side here, just like this. And that's
what I want actually. So I'll keep that selected,
then come here. Now I'm select this text
here to make sure this is set to hog content,
then come here and select this text to make sure
this is set to fixed width. And that's okay.
So out select this, and out creates an auto layout
on this auto layout now, just like this, now
this new auto layout is called brim 25. Yeah. So
inside this new auto layout that I just created,
we have this auto layout here, which is frame 24.
Out select it and not duplicate it vertically just
like this. Now select the frame 25 Auto Layout,
then I'll set the space between the items inside
the auto layout for when I do that, I would come
here and now change the padding around items value
to zero just to have that now I would come here
and I would set the color for this frame 25 auto
layout to this. Now what I'll do is I would set
the corner radius value for this auto layout
to eight. Now the corner radius won't be visible.
And that's because this auto layout here is
staying on top of that auto layout. So I would
select this auto layout here which is at the top,
and I'll come here, I would click on independent
corners here. And I'll set the top left corner
reduced value to eight. And now set the
top right corner reduce value to eight,
just like this outcome here out select this,
click on Independence corners and outset the
bottom right corner reduce value to eight and
I'll set the bottom left corner reduce value
to eight. And that's sorted. Now for each of these
rows here out select this, then come here and I'll
change it horizontal resizing value to fill
container. I'll do that for this also. Do that
for this also. And do that for this. And that's
okay. Now let's see if this responding how we
actually wanted to respond. And it is actually
now let's edit these values that we have here.
So I would come here and how to set this open and
how to set this to previous close and out set this
to market cap. Now for this I'll
change the value to So out, come here,
previous close out, say that plus this
and open, just any value there, actually,
just any value, there will be fine, actually.
So with this, I have successfully created
these components that allow us to show more
details about that stock. So I would come here
and not call this detail table. Actually, I would
call it stock detail table. And I'll save that,
then come here and make it a component. And here
we have that. So I would zoom out, and I'll go
over to this page, and out, bring that component.
So let's come here, click on the Assets tab,
come here, grab this and place it here. So out,
keep it selected, and I'll add a shadow effect,
just like this, then zoom in so that
I can calculate the row spaces better.
So from this item here, I would like to
have 123 and four row spaces people this,
let's zoom out, and let's stretch this to this
point. And that's fine. So I can go ahead, select
this text, so that I'll be able to change the
colors out, select all of this, come here and
change this. To that good, this was not selected.
So I would change that. For this also out,
change it. Now the next component I'd like to have
here will serve as links just in case the user
wishes to read more about the stock and the
company that owns the stock. So I'll go ahead,
and I'll have that it's going to be similar to
what we have here. Now this is me creating this
just the same way I created this stock portfolio
components here. The only difference here is that
I just changed the color from what I have
here to this. So let's zoom in to be sure
that we are placing our items properly. So
outcome here, I would have 1234 Row spaces
before this. And that's okay. So at the bottom
here, I'd have a button component just for a user
who is satisfied with what they see here on
this stock Details page. And this button is
going to be an invest button. So out zooming to
calculate the space better. So I have 123456 Row
spaces here. And I would like to stop at the sixth
rule space. And that's it. So if a user likes what
they see here, on the stock Details page, the
user can go ahead and click on the InVEST button.
If the user is not satisfied, the user
can come here and click on this button
to go back to the previous page where the
user will still have to see all the stocks
listed here. So that's it. So the next page
here will be the page that the user will go to,
when the user clicks on this invest button
here, I'd like us to go ahead and create
that page. So I would duplicate this. So outcome
here, I would rename this to enter stock, amount,
whatever you want to call it is okay.
So outcome here, I'll change this to
enter amount. And that's cool. So I'll go ahead
and I'll have this here. Now this is me using
an input field and a button as simple as that.
So I will zoom in to this point and out calculate
the space better, I would select this item
and out calculates the space from that item,
I would say 123456. So I'd like six rule spaces
there. So I would select this. And I'll make sure
that snaps perfectly. And that's it. Now the space
between this input field and this button is 1234.
And that's fine. How to come here. Now check out
this invest button. And this page is sorted. Now
when the user enters the amount that the user
wishes to invest in the stock with, the user
will go ahead and click on this Proceed button.
Now when the user clicks on this Proceed button,
the user will be taken to another page. Now that
page will be where the user will be presented
with a summary of the investment that
the user is about make. Now outcome here.
I would select this and out duplicate it
and out. Rename this to investments summary.
Now I'll zoom in outcome here. And now take
all of these out. And I'd have this here.
Now this is going to be a summary of the
investment that the user is about to make. And
if the user is okay with the summary that the user
sees here, then the user would go ahead and enter
their secrets been here, before they click on
the InVEST button to finally make the investment.
So outcome here out, select all of these, and out
calculate the row space is better. So I would come
here, I would keep this here, I would make sure
that I have lead zoomin, I'd make sure that I have
123456 Row spaces there. And that's cool. So out,
zoom out to this point, and this page is sorted.
So this is the flow so far. Now when the user
is on the homepage here, and the user wants to
invest, the user will click on this invest link
at the bottom navigation here. This is it here at
the bottom navigation here. When the user clicks
on this link, the user will be taken to the InVEST
page, which is this. And if the user goes through
the list of stocks that we have here, and the user
is interested in investing in one of these stocks,
let's say this one here, the user will go ahead to
click on it. And when the user clicks on it, the
user will be taken to the stock Details page here,
which is this. Now when the user is taken to this
page, the user will read about the stock. If the
user likes what the user sees here, the user will
go ahead and click on the InVEST button here. When
the user does that, the user will be taken to this
page, where the user will have to enter the amount
that the user wishes to invest in that stock with.
Now, when the user enters the amount here, the
user will click on the Proceed button here. When
the user does that, then the user will be taken
to this page where the user will see a summary of
the investments that the user is about to make.
Then if the user is okay with this, the user
will go ahead to enter their secrets pin here.
When the user does that, the user will click on
the InVEST button here for the investments to be
made successfully. So before we proceed further,
I'd like to come here and change this to summary.
So I would keep that selected and align it to the
center horizontally, I'd also come here, select
these and make sure it's aligned to the center
horizontally. Now, I'll come to this page, which
is the Invest page. And I'd like to have a title
here, I'll change this to invest an hour, align it
to the center horizontally, just like that. Now,
when the user clicks on this invest button here,
the user will see a page that says investment
successfully made or investment made or whatever,
whatever just a success message. So I would come
here, I would select this, and I'll duplicate it,
and I would rename this successful investments.
And I'd save that. So what I'm going to have here
will be similar to what I have here. So what I'll
do is out, take out all that I have here on this
page, I'll take this out. Also, I was supposed
to take this out also this debit card title here,
I'll take that out. Also, I'll just select all of
this out, duplicate it. And I bring this in here,
just like this. And I'll zoom in. And I'll just
change this to success. I'll keep it selected
and out, align it to the center horizontally.
Now I'd come here, I'd say go back home. And
that's it. That's sorted. So so far. So so
far, we have achieved the authentication
task, we have achieved the funding task, and
we have achieved the investment task. Now we
are going to go ahead to create more screens that
will actually make the user experience on this app
to be better. So one of those screens will be the
Transaction Details page. And that's the page that
the user will go to when the user clicks on any
of this card here under the recent transactions
section. So if the user clicks on this card,
for example, the user will be taken to a page
where the user will see the full details of this
transaction. So let's go ahead and let's create
that page. So outcome here out select this one
here, and I'll duplicate it. And I have that.
So let's keep it selected, come here. And let's
call this transaction details. And for the
Transaction Details page, I'll take this out. And
I'll take this out. Now this is what I would have
on this transaction details page. This is it's
as simple as this. So first things, first,
let's calculate our row space to be
sure that it's perfectly set. So I'll
have this here and out Count 123456. So
I like this to start here 123456 Out,
snap this correctly, and out snap this correctly.
And that's okay. So this here is to display
the transaction date that that transaction
happened. So this is not complete, actually,
I can give some space here and say 1603, just like
that, so that we will depict the date and time of
the transaction. And that's cool. Now, what
we have here is the transaction amount. And
here we have the amount in words, here we have
the transaction type, which is a withdrawal,
here we have the transaction remark, which is for
Netflix, and the status of that transaction is
successful. So I would select all of this zoom
in. And I would make sure I have 1234 photo
spaces there. Now for the button components
here, how to select this, and I'll make sure I
have 123456, I'll make sure I have six row spaces
there. And that's fine. So if a user comes here,
and the user clicks on one of these transactions,
the user will go to a transaction details page,
where the user will see more details about that
transaction. So I'll go ahead and out create
other pages, that's going to make the experience
on this app to be better. Now, before we do that,
I'd like to give this transaction details page, a
page title. So out, duplicate this, and I'll bring
you here a lot call that transaction details
out, align it to the center horizontally,
just like this. And that's fine. So the next
flow that I'd like to design will be the flow
that the user will go to when the user clicks on
this menu icon here. Now when the user clicks on
this menu icon, I'd like for a menu bar to slide
in with other options that the user can use to
improve their experience on this app. So how do we
make that happen? It simply, so outcome here, I'd
have an iPhone 13 Promax, here, out, rename this
to manage slide bar, and out, keep it selected,
come here, and I would divide the width by two,
just like this. And I'd have this. So I might
decide to go ahead and increase this further. And
what I'll do is this outcome here, I'll just have
the logo here. And I would go ahead to have list
items of menu links. So the first menu link, I
would have here will be recent transactions. I'll
keep that selected here. And I'll change this to
a body small text just like this. Now let's zoom
in. Let's keep this here. I'll keep it selected,
and I would create an auto layout on that text.
Now this auto layout, I would like the auto layout
to have a padding around items value of 16. And
I'd also like the alignment value to be set to the
left. So I would come here now I would keep this
then creates another auto layout on top of it.
Now this new auto layout that I have created
will have a padding around items value of zero,
just like this. Now outcome here out expand
this new auto layout here in the design tree.
When I do that out, select the recent transactions
auto layout, and I'll duplicate it just like this.
Now go ahead to edit all of these two other links.
Before I do that, let's select the main Auto
Layout now, which is frame 34. Here, and let's set
the spacing between items value two, four, just
to have that. So the next link here will be card
management, I'd have this be investment portfolio.
I would have this be request statement. And I'd
have this be settings and that's fine. But I would
come here I would select all of these text.
And I'll change the color to this. And that's
what we have. So whenever the user clicks on On
this menu icon, this is going to slide out from
the left. And that's okay. So let's go ahead to
create the routes that the users will go to when
the users click on this transact link here at the
bottom navigation section. So to do that, I would
come here, I would select this here, and I will
duplicate it. I would rename that to transact,
without zooming out, come here. And I would say,
transact. Keep that selected and out, align that
to the center horizontally, then
I'll take all of these outs. Now,
I'd like to have two card components here, one for
withdrawal action, and one for a deposit action,
as simple as that. So let's go ahead and let's
create those card components. So outcome here out,
create a text here, I'll just say deposits. And
I'll keep this text selected. Come here, and I'll
go with the headline three bold text, just like
this. Now, I'd come here and I'd have a 48 by 48
px frame layout, with a corner reduce of 100,
then I'd come here and I'll give it a color,
that's green, then go to be further icon
slogan. And I'll get an incoming icon there,
which is this, this is our incoming arrow icon
out, place this here, then come here and set
the constraints value to center and center.
Now out, select the icon vector, and now change
the color to this. So I would bring this here,
select this, and then create an auto layout on it.
Now for this auto layout, I would come here
and I'd set the alignment property to center.
When I do that, I'd come here and outset the space
in between items value to 16, then go ahead to add
a fill color. When I add the fill color out, come
here and I'll set the padding around items value
to eight. To have that then I would go ahead to
set the corner reduce value to eight. Now outcome
here now select the deposit text and change the
horizontal resizing value from hog content to fill
container. So this is the deposit action card
that I would have on that page. outcome here,
I would rename this to deposit action, save that,
and then come here and click on Create components.
Now select this text and I'll change the color to
this. Now I would come here now I would go to this
page. And I would bring in VAT components. This
is it. I'll keep it selected. And I'll give it a
shadow effect out zoom into this point. I'll bring
this here. And I'd make sure I have 123456 Row
spaces. And that's okay. So out stretch this to
this point like this. And I'll create a component
or withdrawal. I'll duplicate this component,
which is the master component, take notes. And I
would detach instance, when I detach instance out,
select the circular frame there out, make this red
out, select the arrow frame there, and I
would set the rotation value to 180 degrees.
And that's sorted, as easy as that. So I would
come here select it's come here and go to the
design three and rename this to withdraw action.
When I do that, I'll keep it selected. And I'll
click on Create components here. And that's
okay. So outcome here now, I'll bring this in
give it a shadow effect, like this, I would
have this day here. And I would spread this
to this point. And that's okay. So finally, on
this page, I would love to have a button here
that can be used to perform the adding of card
action. So I would keep this here I'd have 16 px
margin space here, which is to row spaces.
One and two are keep the bottom selected.
out, set the top padding value to eight and the
bottom padding value to eight. Then I'll change
the text contents there to add card just like
that. And that's sorted. So this is the page
that the users will go to when the users click on
this transact link here at the bottom Navigation
component. So this is where I would stop for
this project in regards to creating screens
and outs stop here because we have achieved the
actual user task for this app. Now I'd like you
to take this as your own assignments and and when
you are done. You can Tagami tweets on Twitter,
my Twitter handle is you can go ahead and
tag me to your assignment on Twitter. Now,
the assignment is this, I'd like you to have a
notifications icon here. And the notification icon
should take users to a page of notifications
when they click on it. And the notifications
can be anything. It can be newsletters, it can
be transaction notifications, it can be anything
at all. Now place the notification icon here and
create a Notifications page that users will go to
when the user clicks on the notification icon.
Now, after that, come here and create a route
or create a page that the user will go to when
the user select add another card, create a page
that the user can use to add their debit card
details to this app. The third assignment
will be this, come here and create a page that
the user can use to request for their statement.
After that, create a settings page now on this
settings page, lets the user be able to set
their secrets been there. Now over here, which is
the card management link, the user should be able
to delete a card that they have added to this
app, or add another card that they want to add
to this app. So that should be possible when the
user clicks on card management here. This should
take the user to a page where they will be able
to see all the cards that they have on this app.
And and also, they should have the ability on
that page to add and delete cards. Now take notes,
this Add Card button here should take the
user to the same page that you would create
for this add another card here, just like
that. And also, this recent transactions
link here should take the users to a dedicated
page for the list of all recent transactions.
This investment portfolio link here should
take the user to a dedicated page of all
the investments that the user has made on this
app. So go ahead to build all of those pages,
so that you can have a full and complete user
experience. Now, finally, for the assignment,
just before I forget, come here and create
a Forgot Password page, create a page here
that the user can use to reset their password
just in case the user forgets their password.
And that's going to be it. So at this stage, what
we are going to do is to create a prototype of all
of these designs that we have created, we are
going to link this perfectly and see how it's
going to work. So to do that, let's zoom in out
come here, I will start from the splash screen. So
I would select it. Come here click on prototype.
When I click on prototype, I would come here and I
would connect the splash screen to this page. Now
the action will be an on tap action. And that's
because this is a mobile app actually. So we are
actually supposed to tap this screen with our
fingers. Now when the user taps on the screen,
the user should move to or should navigate to,
you can see the action here should navigate
to the author selection page, which is this.
Now the transition animation or the navigation
animation should be a smart animation. So it's
going to be an ease in animation. And I would like
this ease in animation to be for 800 milliseconds.
Actually, I'd like this to be an ease in and out
animation, just like this. Yeah, that's better for
me. So outcome here now. And I will say okay, when
the user clicks on the login button here, the user
should go to the login page. And I'll keep all of
the sets the way it is. Now when the user clicks
on the get started button here, the user should
go to the signup page. So I would come here,
click on this login button here. And I would say
when the user clicks on that login button after
after passing in their email address and password,
the user should go to the homepage, which is this
over here. When the user clicks on the
signup button, the user should go to the
verification page where the user will have
to enter the verification code sent to their
phone numbers. Now when the user types in the
verification code here, the user should click on
the Verify button. And when the user clicks on
the Verify button, this should show like a pop up
so I would connect it to this. So out connect this
And I'd keep it as on top, then for the action
out habit set to open overlay, then come here
and I'll keep it sets a centered actually,
after setting these two Centered Outcome here, and
I won't select this option. And that's because I
don't want the user to close the pop up. If
they mistakenly click outside the pop, I'd
like the user to click on proceed here. So this
other option here out selected, this is the add
background behind overlay property or
the add background behind overlay option.
When I select it, it means that when the popup
shows up, the background will be faded. So I
would set the Opacity value to 35%. And I would
like the animation to be an instant animation.
And that's going to be okay. Now, when the
user clicks on this Proceed button, the user
should be taken to the homepage. Now, when you are
creating a prototype like this, you can just take
the connection here to any page at all, then come
here and set it to the page you want to set it to.
So I would come here and I would select Home. And
you can see that the connection has gone to the
homepage, just like this. So the authentication
is set. Now when the users come to the homepage,
and the users click on this menu icon, the user
should be taken to the menu, slide bar them here,
this is what should show up when the user
clicks on that menu icon. Now, I would want that
menu slide bar or that slide bar menu to
actually slide in from the left. So I'll click on
this connection here to have the Interaction
Details page show up. Now for the action here,
I would set these to open overlay outcome here and
I'll set it to manual. When I set it to manual,
it means I'll be the one to set how the
interaction is going to happen. So I'll grab this,
and I'll place this here, just like this. This is
how it's going to look like when you click on that
menu icon. Now outcome here. And I would say close
this slide by menu, when the user clicks outside
of it, I would select that and over here out have
a background behind overlay properties selected,
also an out have the Opacity value set to 35%.
Now for the animation, I'll change this from
instance, to move in just like this. And for
the moving action out habits moving from the
left and out have the speed of that animation
set to 800 milliseconds. Now outcome here,
I'll click on this font Account button here. And
I'd say okay, when a user clicks on this button,
this should show us a pop up. So we all know how
to set a pop up, right. So I'll change this to
open overlay. Keep it set centered, and out add
a background behind overlay action. And also, if
the user chooses not to fund the account anymore,
the user can just click outside the pop up and go
back to the homepage. So I would select that. I'll
keep this set to 35%. And for the animation here,
I'll keep it set instance. So I'll close this.
Now if the user selects the bank transfer option,
the user should come here, as easy as that.
And if the user clicks on copy account number,
this account number will be copied to the user's
clipboard. And when that happens, the user will
come here and click on this arrow here to go
back to the homepage out sets this from instant
to smart animates. And that's okay. So if the
user clicks on the debit card option here,
the user would be taken to this page. If the user
is taken to this page, and the user types in the
amounts that they are trying to actually fund
the account with, then the user will go ahead to
tap or to click on the fund account button here.
And when the user does that, the user would come
to this page where the user will have a message
that says account funded successfully. Now,
at this stage, we are going to want the user to go
directly to the InVEST page. So I'll select this
button now. And I'll take this flow to the InVEST
page, which is this. So when the user gets here,
I'll take this menu icon out here actually,
when the user gets here, and the user wants
to invest in one of these listed stocks, let's
say this one, the user will click on it and the
user will be taken to the stock Details page.
When the user gets to the stock Details page and
the user is okay with all of these details here.
The user will click On the InVEST button here.
And when the user does that, the user will come
here and be required to enter the amounts that
they wish to invest in that stocks with. When the
user enters the amount and the user clicks on the
Proceed button, the user will be taken to this
page, which is where the user will see a summary
of the investment that the user is about to make.
Now, if the user is satisfied with this summary,
the user will go ahead to type in their secrets
pin here, and then click on this invest button.
And when the user does that, the user will be
taken to this page, which is a success page,
that's going to let the user know that, hey, you
have successfully invested in that stock. So the
user will come here and click on the Go back home
button, and out, take this back to the homepage,
how to select home here. So let's come here, let's
see the other links that we have not created. So
let's say the US is trying to see the transaction
detail of any of this recent transaction. Yeah,
let's see the withdrawal transaction here, I
would click on it to select it. And I would
link this to the Transaction Details page, which
is this. So if the user clicks on that transaction
card, there, the user will be taken to this page.
And if the user goes through the whole detail,
and the user is satisfied, when the user clicks
on done, the user will go back to the homepage,
outcome here and select home here. Same will
happen if the user comes here, clicks on that
arrow, the user will go back to the home page.
So you can see that we are creating lots of
connections and flows here. Lots of connections
and flows here. So let's go back to the homepage,
and let's see the flow that we have not created.
So this is the home page here. So this home link
here is safe to be there. Now let's say the user
clicks on this invest link here, which is in the
bottom navigation components, the user should
be taken to the InVEST page. If the user clicks
on this transact link here, the user should be
taken to the transact page. So if I come here,
now out still connect this, this should go to the
homepage. And since this is the Invest page here,
it means we are here. So this should go to
the transact page. I'll do that for this also.
So let's come here. Let's see, let's see what
we have not connected yet. So if the user comes
to the transact page, and the user clicks on the
deposits card here, the user should have that pop
up, show up, that would require them to select if
they want to deposit with bank transfer or their
debit card, it should be the same flow. Now over
here, I should actually change this to withdraw.
If the user clicks on this withdraw card
here, the user should be taken to a page
where they would have to enter the amount and the
destination bank that they are trying to withdraw
their funds to. So this is also going
to be a part of your assignment.
Go ahead and create that flow. When you create
it. Go ahead and tag me on Twitter for my comment.
So let's go ahead and let's present this flow.
And let's see how it's going to look like.
So I would come here, I would select the splash
screen. And I'd come here and click on present.
So when I click on present, I would have the
splash screen show up here. When I click on it,
I would have the option to either login or get
started. So I'll click on get started. And here we
are on the signup form page. So if the user enters
their email address, phone number and password
when the user clicks on the signup button, the
user will be required to enter the verification
code. When the user enters that the user will
click on the Verify button here. And a pop up will
show up here saying phone number verified. Now
you'll see that when I click outside the pop up,
the pop up won't go away until I come here and
I click on the Proceed button. When I do that,
I'll be taken to the homepage. Now here we are in
the homepage. Now if I come here and I click on
this menu icon here, you will see that this menu
slide bar or this slide bar menu and how you call
it is fine. This slide by menu slides in from the
left. When I click outside of it, it goes back in.
Now let's check the font accounts flow. When I
click on it, I would have this pop up show up here
that says Select method. Now let's say I choose
to select the bank transfer method, I would have
this show up here, I'd be able to copy the account
number. And when I'm done, I would come here and I
would click on this arrow icon here. To go back to
the homepage. Now let's click on the bond Account
button once more, and let's select the debit
card method, you can see that I'll be taken to
this page where I would have to enter the amount
that I'm trying to fund this account with. Now,
let's say I type in the amount, I would come
here and I'll click on the fund account button,
just like this. And I'd have this message that
says accounts funded successfully. Now if I go
ahead and click on this invest button, I'll
be taken to the InVEST page, which is this.
And over here, I would see a list of stocks. Now
I'd like to present this in full screen actually,
so that we can see better. So over here, I
would see a list of stocks that I can invest in.
Now let's say I'd like to invest in this one here,
I would click on it. And I would see full details
about this stock here. Now, I don't have some of
my components showing here. So I would go back to
my design outcome here. So this is the stock
Details page. So this three buttons actually
not inside that layout. So I would select
the three of them. And I'll take them inside
that layout. And that sorted. Now when I come back
here, you will see that I have that here. So let's
go back to our full screen presentation. So if the
user likes what they see here in the stock Details
page, the user will go ahead to click on the
InVEST button here. And when the user does that,
the user will enter the amount that they would
like to invest in that stocks with. When the user
does that, the user will go ahead to click on the
Proceed button here. Now that flow is not created.
So I would come back to our design here,
I would click on this Proceed button here,
click on prototype. And now let's see what the
problem is. So I came here and I clicked on this
connection link here. And I changed this from
on drag to on top. Now when I come back here,
and I click on the Proceed button here, you
will see that we are taken to the Summary page.
Now this page will be the page where the user
will see a summary of the investments that
the user is about to make. And if the user is OK
with this, the user will go ahead to enter their
secrets pin here and then click on the InVEST
button. Now the InVEST button is not active also
outcome here and out see the problem for that. So
I would click on invest here. And I would select
the connection flow here. And as you can see here,
there is an undo drag event here, outcome here.
And I'll delete that on drag event here. And I'll
just leave this set to tap now. But the tap event,
there is no navigation destination. So I would
set this. First of all out to take note of the
screen here. This is the successful investment
page. So I would come here and I would go to the
successful investment page. And that's sorted.
Now when I come here, and I click on invest,
I'd be taken to the success page.
Now when I click on Go back home,
I'll be taken back to the homepage. Now that is
after I have successfully invested in a stock.
Now, what happens if I come here, and I click
on one of the recent transactions here, let's
say the withdrawal transaction here, you would see
that I'll be taken to the transaction details page
for that transaction. When I'm done going
through it out, click on Done. And I'll be
taken back to the homepage. Now what's going to
happen if I come here and I click on this invest
link at the bottom navigation components. I'll be
taken to the InVEST page still. And I'd be able
to still invest in a stock just like this.
Now what happens if I come here and I click on
the transact link here or be taken to this page
where I'd have the option to deposit funds or
withdraw funds. And I'd also have the option to
Add Card. Now if I am okay with this outcome here,
and I'll click on this arrow to go back to
the homepage and that arrow is not active.
So I would have that sorted out come here
and connect that arrow to be homepage
and it's going to be an on tap event. So when I
come back here, when I click on that arrow now,
you will see that I'm taken back to the homepage.
So go ahead, create the order pitches and the
other route as your assignment, then tag me to
it on Twitter. So that's that for this course.
If you found this cost to be helpful, go ahead,
click on the subscribe button, leave a comment
in the comment section. And stay tuned for more
content. Thank you and see you in another course.